programming throwdown episode number six assembly take it away jason hey so i'm here in the valley now which is uh silicon valley which is it's an amazing place Take it away, Jason. internet it's like i drive on the road and it's like oh there's intel there's microsoft there's linkedin there's all these different websites um so it's it's kind of a i don't know it's sort of a it's a really cool feeling but sometimes it can even be kind of eerie you know overwhelming yeah yeah i guess it's sort of like uh you don't think that these websites like like need a bunch of people you think it's maybe like a few people in a basement or i don't know somehow like i didn't connect websites like linkedin with corporate america but i mean this like makes it all like very opaque so now when you go to those websites do you think of their actual building instead of the website yeah yeah exactly like now
Programming Throwdown 第六期，汇编语言。Jason，开始吧。嘿，我现在在硅谷，这真是一个神奇的地方。开始吧，Jason。互联网，就像我开车在路上，看到英特尔、微软、领英，还有各种各样的网站。这感觉真的很酷，但有时甚至会让人觉得有点诡异，你知道，让人不知所措。是啊，我想你不会觉得这些网站需要那么多人，你可能觉得只有几个人在地下室里工作，或者我不知道，我没法把领英这样的网站和美国企业联系起来。但这让一切变得非常不透明，所以现在当你访问这些网站时，你会想到它们真实的建筑，而不是网站本身吗？是的，完全是这样，就像现在
it's like it almost like there's two faces. There's the physical manifestation. And there's still the website. There's the LinkedIn building. Which is like this red brick. Kind of like old looking building. With a bunch of oak trees. And then there's the website.
这几乎就像有两副面孔。一个是物理实体，另一个依然是网站。有领英大楼，看起来像那种红砖砌成的老式建筑，周围有很多橡树。然后才是网站。
You can't help but conflate the two concepts. Huh. Yeah. It's pretty nuts. So what have you been up to lately yeah um pretty much the same stuff as as always uh it's been really hot here so you left just in the nick of time i guess and uh it's uh it's been really brutally hot and terrible outside and so uh that's been kind of interesting it's doing a number on my grass so uh oh yeah yep um but i shouldn't complain anyways it's nice to have a yard but it's a pain number on my grass so uh oh yeah yeah um but i shouldn't complain
你忍不住会把这两个概念混为一谈。哈。是啊。这太疯狂了。那么你最近在忙些什么？嗯，基本上和往常一样。这里一直很热，我想你走得正是时候。外面热得离谱，非常糟糕，这挺有意思的，我的草坪都快被晒死了。哦，是啊。不过我不该抱怨，有个院子挺好的，但确实很麻烦。
anyways it's nice to have a yard but it's a pain a lot of work and yeah when we got here it uh it actually rained and it was overcast for the first week or so and people were just in shock because i guess it doesn't rain between you know april and and november or something like that and uh but yeah now it's starting to get sunny, which is kind of nice. Yeah, awesome. Yeah. All right, well, I guess we'll go to the news. So the first news item I see here is that Netflix is now the single largest source of
总之，有个院子很好，但确实很费力。我们刚到这里时，确实下过雨，第一周左右一直阴天，人们都惊呆了，因为我猜四月到十一月之间通常是不下雨的。但现在开始变晴了，这挺好的。太棒了。好的，我想我们该聊聊新闻了。我看到的第一个新闻是，Netflix 现在是美国黄金时段互联网流量的最大单一来源。我想那大概是晚上6点到10点，也就是大多数人坐下来看电视的时间。他们不再看电视，而是看 Netflix。是的，没错，互联网上大约30%的流量都是 Netflix。这太疯狂了。不久前，我和我妻子取消了有线电视，只保留了互联网。我们甚至连基本的本地频道都不看，除此之外，我们所有的视频都是在线观看的。我
internet traffic during prime time in the United States, I guess that is. So that would be, what, like 6 to 10, which is when most people sit down and watch TV. Instead of watching their TV, they sit down and watch tv instead of watching their tv they're watching cable or instead of watching cable they're watching netflix yeah yeah exactly something like what 30 percent of the entire traffic on the internet is netflix yeah that's pretty crazy now a while ago my wife and i canceled uh our cable and we just have our internet and we do this we don't even we just get the few basic network channels that are local and uh other than that we watch all of our video online and i've
一直鼓励人们这样做，这是省钱的好方法，而且我们大多数人本来就在网上看很多视频，所以我很支持这一点。是的，搬家的时候我承诺过，你一直让我换成 Netflix。说实话，除了懒，我真的没有理由拒绝。但这次搬家，我决定试一试。我喜欢它。我是说，我喜欢点播功能，也喜欢通过邮寄收到 DVD。
tried to encourage people this is a great way to save money and most of us watch a lot of video on the internet anyways so uh yeah i'm a big proponent of this yeah i i just uh you know as part of moving i made a commitment to uh you know you've always been telling me to switch to Netflix. And, you know, I really had no argument against other than being lazy. But, you know, with this move and everything, I decided to give it a shot. I love it. I mean, I love the on demand. I like, you know, renting the or getting the DVDs in the mail.
我注意到有很多较新的电影只能在 DVD 上看到。你知道为什么吗？是的，这和授权有关。制片厂不想让 Netflix 在 DVD 发行时立即提供流媒体服务，因为他们不想影响销量。而且他们也不愿意把一些电影给 Netflix，因为他们觉得赚不到那么多钱。但这种情况正在逐渐改善。抱歉，我只是觉得我们真的需要重新定义艺术、艺术的价值以及艺术贡献的价值，特别是在这种可以免费复制艺术的技术背景下。
I noticed that there's a lot of especially newer newer movies, that you can only get on DVD. Do you know why that is? Yeah, so it has to do with the licensing. So the studios don't want to let Netflix carry it right away or as soon streaming as releasing DVDs because they don't want it to hurt sales or whatever. And then also they're hesitant to let Netflix to have some movies because they don't think they're going to make as much money or whatnot but there's yeah getting more and more yep sorry oh no i just i feel like uh you know we really have to sort of redefine like art and the value of art and and the value of like artistic contribution in light of technologies that can
是的。好吧，我唯一怀念的就是在 Netflix 看电影和老电视剧，然后使用像 Hulu 这样的网站，美国很多大型电视网的节目都在上面。我唯一怀念的是现场体育赛事。如果你是个铁杆体育迷，有时很难看到那些在付费体育频道播出的比赛。如果你有有线宽带，你知道你自动会有一些有线频道，对吧？即使你没有有线电视，我想你也能免费获得一部分频道。没错，没错。我
duplicate said art for free. Yeah. Well, the only thing that I really miss going this way is between Netflix for movies and older TV series and then using a website like here in the United States we have Hulu, which is a lot of the big networks shows go on there. The only thing I really missed is live sports it's sometimes if you're a big sports fan it's hard to get those sports games that would appear on a premium sports channel if you have um if you have cable internet you know you automatically have some cable channels right even if you don't have cable television like i think you get a subset of the channels for free that's right that's right i
想知道你是否可以每年付一定的钱来获得体育频道？比如我知道你可以花一百美元一年买 NHL 频道，我想知道没有有线电视能不能买到。通常不行，那叫“自选套餐”（a la carte pricing）。至少在美国，有线电视提供商一直不愿采用这种模式，让你选择“我要这个频道，我要那个频道”。部分原因是频道本身是作为套餐卖给互联网或有线电视提供商的。所以他们必须面对这样一个事实：这些公司不想只卖一个频道，他们想卖一整套频道，因为那样赚得更多。
wonder can you pay the however much it is a year to get the sports channel like like i know you can get the nhl channel for like a hundred dollars a year i wonder if you can get that without cable television um normally not they that's called a la carte pricing and at least in the united states the cable providers have been hesitant to go to a la carte pricing where you can kind of just choose, I want this channel and I want that channel and I want the other channel. And part of that is because the channels themselves are sold as packages to the internet or to the cable providers. So they have to deal with the fact that those companies don't want to sell them just one channel. They want to sell them a package of channels because that's how they make more money that way.
哦，明白了。是的，我看到亚马逊已经达到了那个临界点，电子书的销量超过了纸质书。我觉得这太迷人了。是的，当这个消息传出时，互联网上有很多讨论，人们有点困惑这到底意味着什么。哦，亚马逊肯定没有统计他们所有的实体书，可能只是统计了平装书或精装书。然后他们肯定把 Kindle 上人们下载的免费书也算进去了。
Oh, gotcha. Yeah, so I see that Amazon has actually reached that threshold, that crossover point, to where they're selling more e-books than hard copy books. I think that's fascinating. Yeah, there was a lot of buzz about this on the internet when this story first hit, and people were kind of confused about exactly what did this mean. Oh, and Amazon must be not counting all of their physical books, like just counting paperback books or just counting hardback books. And then they must be counting on the Kindle side the free books that people download on the Kindle.
但亚马逊出来澄清说，这不包括人们在 Kindle 上下载的免费书籍。这些数据只统计了购买书籍的人，而且包括了他们销售的所有实体书，即平装书和精装书。所以，电子书销量超过普通书籍，这个数字确实令人震惊。是的，我的意思是，我不知道。你觉得这对出版商意味着什么？我忍不住觉得中间商——无论是我们之前提到的电影行业还是图书出版行业——正在被完全排除在外。你是说中间人，那些负责中间环节的人？对，就像亚马逊的例子，那些负责出版和装订书籍的人。而在 Netflix 的例子中，那些负责广播视频内容的有线电视公司，在现代互联网时代，这两者都在被边缘化。是的，而且实际上，
But Amazon came out and said this does not count the free books that people download on the kindle but amazon came out and said this does not count um the free books that are downloaded these are only people who buy books who pay for books and then also that it includes all physical manifestations of books that they sell so paperback and hardback so it really is an astonishing number that they have they sell more ebooks than regular books yeah i mean this mean, this is, I don't know. I mean, what do you think this means for publishers? I mean, I can't help but feel like the people in the middle, and this is both for what we talked about earlier with Netflix,
他们很快就指出了这一点，并认为这很糟糕，因为他们会失业之类的。我想这归结为经济学问题。但是，我不想说得太刻薄，但我们真的不能为了维持那些所谓的“死重”而负责，对吧？
with the movie industry and with the book publishing industry, that the middle people are sort of getting completely cut out of the loop. You mean the middlemen, the people who like go between them? Right, like in the case of Amazon, the people who, you know, publish and bind the books. And in the case of Netflix, you know, the people, the cable companies who broadcast, you know, the video content, both of those people are getting cut out of the loop in the modern internet era. Yeah, and actually,
如果他们没有立足之地，这就像我们——这可能是一个陈词滥调，而且可能并不准确——当汽车刚出现时，那些卖马鞭的人，一旦每个人都有了汽车，就不再需要买马鞭了，也没人养马了。但我们为什么要为他们感到难过呢？他们中有些人适应了，进入了新的行业，找到了新的赚钱方式。这些公司需要寻找新的出路，而不是死守现有的赚钱方式。他们必须找到新的赚钱方式和提供价值的新途径，而不是仅仅为了从剩下的少数客户身上榨取最后一分钱而坑害他们。
they're very quick to point out that fact and that that's bad because they're going to lose jobs or whatever. And I guess that comes to an economics thing. But, you know, I hate to be harsh, but we can't really be responsible for, you know, trying to carry along what amounts to dead weight, you know?
是的，完全正确。我记得读过一些历史资料，在20世纪40年代和50年代，当女性开始获得选举权并进入职场时，人们抱怨说，现在劳动力过剩了，这会压低所有人的工资。但现在回顾过去，随着社会学的进步，没有人会剥夺女性工作的权利，就像100或150年前那样。所以我认为这里的情况类似，我们之所以受到阻力，是因为存在某种教条，或者人们在核心业务上根深蒂固。但50或100年后，我们可能根本不想回顾今天。是的，我的意思是，
If they don't have a place, it's kind of like when we, and this the probably cliched and probably not actually accurate but um you know when automobiles first started coming about and the people who sold whips for the horses you know when the car nobody needed to buy those anymore once everybody had cars and nobody kept horses anymore but it's like we shouldn't why should we feel bad for them they have there are some of them adapted and took on new industries and new ways to make money and that's what these companies need to look to do instead of defending so staunchly their existing ways of making money they got to find new ways to make money and new ways to provide benefit not just you know screwing over their
这是一件有趣的事情，只有少数人在大声疾呼，因为如果你身处这些行业，你会非常在意，当有人试图从根本上消除你的工作或把你踢出局时，你会大声尖叫。就像在某些情况下，作者可以直接向消费者销售作品，作者赢了，消费者赢了，这是一个更有效的市场。所以从经济学角度来看——虽然我不是经济学家——这是一件好事。你希望市场更有效率，你不希望有低效率，而中间商就代表了低效率。所以他们大声尖叫是因为他们快要失业了。而其他人其实并不在乎。
customers to try to get every last penny out of the few who stay with them yeah exactly i remember reading something in uh um you know historically in the 1940s 1950s as women were beginning to get suffrage and get and become part of the workforce and things like that that people were complaining that oh now you have this this surplus in the workforce and it's going to force, you know, drive wages down for everybody and things like that. But looking back on it now with, you know, with our advance in sociology, you know, no one would take that away, you know, and say that women shouldn't be allowed to work as was the case, you know, 100, 150 years ago. So I think that it's similar here where we're getting this pushback because there's this dogma or this or this you know people have been entrenched in their in their core business but uh you know 50 100 years from now we'd probably just we wouldn't want to look back to to this day yeah and i mean it's
他们只是想便宜、快速地买到他们想要的东西。所以，这就是为什么他们看起来不像是在大声疾呼。但他们其实是在乎的，只是他们不知道自己在乎。是的，绝对是这样。而且在这种情况下，有巨大的财富处于危险之中。我的意思是，图书出版商，还有有线电视公司。中佛罗里达大学的体育场之所以叫“Bright House 体育场”是有原因的。是的，我想我们应该向不住在这个地区的人解释一下，那是因为
it's one of those interesting things where it's a few people you know shouting very loudly to be heard because if you're in those industries you care a lot and you're going to scream very loudly when somebody tries to basically get rid of your job or you know cut you out like uh is going to happen in some of these cases where authors can sell directly to consumers but the authors win the consumers win it's a more efficient market so from an economic standpoint you know which i'm an economist, but that's a better thing. You want markets to be more efficient. You don't want inefficiencies, which is what the middlemen represent. And so they're screaming loudly because they're getting ready to lose their jobs. And then everybody else kind of doesn't really care either way.
他们是当地的有线电视提供商。没错，就是这样。有线电视公司。他们收取——我不知道他们的广告价格是多少——但他们每月收取相当大的一笔钱，本质上只是为了让电子在电线上移动，而这些基础设施的资本成本早已收回了。是的，每个人都有自己的权利。如果人们愿意支付，没有什么能阻止他们收费。是的，绝对是这样。人们似乎很乐意支付。所以你放了一篇关于苹果试图
They just want to be able to buy what they want cheaply and quickly when they want it. And so, you know, that's why it doesn't seem like they're shouting very loudly. But they actually do care. They just don you know that's why it doesn't seem like they're shouting very loudly but they actually do care they just don't know that they care yeah yeah definitely and there's in this case there's just a gigantic amount of wealth on the line for yeah i mean you know book publishers i mean and and uh you know the cable companies i mean the the uh ucf university of central florida arena is called the bright House Stadium for a reason. Yeah, which I guess we should explain to people who don't live in the region that that is because
针对个人应用开发者的文章，或者不是，是其他人针对个人应用开发者，对吧？基本上，最近新闻中普遍存在的一个现象是“专利流氓”。即使是那些不是专利流氓的人——好吧，首先让我们解释一下什么是专利流氓。什么是专利流氓？是一个又高又毛茸茸、拿着大棒的专利怪人吗？是的，住在桥下。基本上，专利流氓是指某个人、
they're a local cable provider. Right, that's right. Cable company. And so they charge, you know, I don't know what their advertised charges, what their advertised prices are, but they charge, you know, a substantial amount of money per month to essentially just move electrons across a wire in which the capital costs have already been paid. Yeah, well, everybody's got their right. If people are willing to pay that, there's nothing to stop them from charging that. Yeah, definitely. People seem happy to pay that. So you put an article in here about apple trying
企业或公司，他们没有盈利的业务，通常不是任何特定领域的参与者，但通过自己的开发人员或从其他公司购买，获得了许多有用的专利。他们本质上雇佣了一个强大的法律团队，去起诉那些他们认为侵犯了其往往非常笼统和开放式专利的公司，以此来赚钱。所以基本上，专利流氓想针对苹果和每一家大公司，因为这些公司非常有钱，而且他们通常会选择和解。
to go after individual app developers or not other people going after individual app developers right so basically you know one thing that's been sort of pervasive in the news recently has been has been patent trolling and even people who aren't patent trolls, well, first let's explain what a patent troll is. What is a patent troll? Is that a person that is very tall and hairy and carries a large club made of patents? It's, yeah, and lives under a bridge. Basically, a patent troll is somebody who,
对他们来说，和解的成本比支付法律费用来辩护要低，即使他们赢了。没错，完全正确。但现在发生的情况是，很多公司都有完整的法律团队，苹果、谷歌、微软，所有这些大公司都有一个法律执行团队，如果必要的话，他们可以对这些专利流氓施以重拳。所以流氓们决定针对开发者，特别是那些为苹果产品（如 iPod 和 iPad）开发应用的个人开发者。因此，专利流氓会去起诉那些通常是小型初创公司或五六人团队的应用开发者，因为他们知道这些开发者没有足够的法律代表。
a business, a corporation, who does not have a, you know, profitable endeavor, does not, you know, typically, you know, isn't a big player in any particular arena, but, you know, has acquired either through, you know, their own developers or through purchasing it from another company, has acquired, you know, many, one or several patents that are of use, and essentially hires a strong legal team to sort of go after companies who they feel are violating their often very umbrella and open-ended patents in an attempt to earn money. So basically what's going on here is the patent trolls want to go after Apple and every large company because these companies are very wealthy and they would often settle.
在这种情况下，这篇文章真正阐明的是，被起诉的人只是在使用苹果的 SDK。换句话说，苹果为你提供了一系列功能。在这个特定的例子中，是一些让你进行“应用内购买”的功能。所以它让你在特定应用程序内购买商品。显然，这违反了 Lodsis 公司的一些专利。所以 Lodsis 正在起诉每一个调用此功能的应用程序开发者。这篇文章暗示——或者说直接指出了——苹果真的应该动用他们的法律团队去对付这些专利流氓，否则人们就不会为这个平台开发应用了。
It costs less for them to settle than to pay the legal expenses to defend them even if they win. Right, exactly. they win right exactly um but what's happening is you know a lot of these companies have entire legal teams you know apple google microsoft all these big companies have a whole team of legal uh enforcers who can uh you know bring down the club if they have to on some of these patent trolls now so what the trolls have decided to do is to go after developers, especially small-time developers who are making apps for Apple products like the iPod and the iPad. So the patent troll will go and sue the app developer who is often a small startup or a five, six-person company, knowing that they don't have adequate legal representation.
是的，我想这必须由我们的法律体系来处理。它需要适应这样一个事实：不再是少数几家大公司向人们销售产品，现在是一个“一对多”的关系（商店对用户），而是一个“多对多”的关系，许多人从许多卖家那里购买，许多卖家向许多人销售。所以，就像你说的，你可以去开发一个应用，只有10或20个人购买，这完全没问题。但如果这些人能够找上门来说：“嘿，因为你用我们的专利赚了一千美元，我们要向你收取五千美元”，那你只能关门大吉了，因为你付不起。
And in this case, what this article really elucidates is that the people who are being sued here are just using the Apple SDK. So in other words, Apple provides you with a series of functions. In this case, this particular instance is some functions that let you, I think, in-app purchasing. So it lets you buy items from while you're inside a particular application. And apparently that violates some patent from this company, Lodsis. So Lodsis is going and suing every app developer that calls this function. So what this article is sort of hinting at is that or i guess it goes right out and says it is that you know apple really should engage their legal team to go after some of these patent trolls because otherwise people won't develop for the platform
没错。为了说明这有多荒谬，想象一下，如果你非常喜欢模型飞机，你组装模型飞机并在店里出售，你可以卖组装好的或未组装的，而有人——你基本上是在处理套件。你买了一个包含所有零件的套件，比如机翼组件和无刷电机等，来驱动飞机。你组装好飞机，然后在店里卖掉。假设那个套件的机翼组件侵犯了某项专利。好吧，最终卖给你套件的公司，在我看来，应该负责。是的，但现在他们做的是，仅仅因为你购买了侵犯专利的东西就去起诉你。在这种情况下，这更荒谬，因为苹果已经与这家 Lodsis 公司和解了。所以苹果并没有侵犯专利，因为他们已经付钱给这家公司了。所以在我看来，这家公司根本站不住脚。
yeah i mean i guess this is something that is gonna have to be handled by our legal system that adapting to the fact instead of having a few big companies that sell to people now it's instead of a what is that a one-to-many relationship with the you know store being one and the people being many now you have a many-to-many relationship where you have many people buying from many sellers and many sellers selling to a few people. And so, you know, you, like you said, you can go make an app and, you know, have only 10 or 20 people buy your app and that's perfectly fine. But if these people are able to come after you and say, Hey, you know, we're going to charge you $5,000 because you made a thousand dollars
是的，电子前沿基金会（EFF）的这篇文章基本上是在呼吁采取行动，说苹果需要站出来保护他们的开发者，因为让开发者在没有帮助的情况下独自面对这些诉讼是不公平的，考虑到他们知道这些人无法为自己辩护。没错。看到 EFF 的文章很有趣，他们并不是真的站在苹果这边。更像是他们在试图推动苹果做点什么。
using our patent, then you're just going to have to close up shop because you can't afford to pay that right and i mean just to draw an analogy of how ridiculous this is imagine if you are really into model planes and you buy you know and you assemble model planes and you sell them in your store and you can sell assembled and unassembled etc and somebody you know and you're just you're basically dealing in terms of kits. So you buy a kit which has all of the parts, the wing assembly and the brushless motors, et cetera, to power the plane. And you'll you'll assemble the plane and then sell it at your store. And let's say that that kit, you know, the wing assembly is violating some patent. Well, the company that sold you the kit ultimately you know in my opinion should be responsible yeah but it's like now what they're doing is going after you for just
但是，EFF 几乎讨厌苹果，对吧？是的，那是真的。所以听到他们谈论苹果，这确实证明了苹果在当今数字世界中的普及程度。说到事物的变化，我看到一篇文章说马克·扎克伯格想让13岁以下的孩子使用 Facebook。目前，你必须是一个极其聪明的人，才能明白即使你不到13岁，你仍然可以点击那个“我已满13岁”的按钮并登录。所以实际上，有很多报道显示 Facebook 上有数百万13岁以下的用户，但这在技术上是不允许的。他们
taking something that for buying something that violated a patent and in this case it's even more ridiculous because apple has already settled with this lotsodsis company. So Apple's not violating the patent because they paid off this company. So really, this company shouldn't have a leg to stand on, in my opinion. Yeah, and it looked like this article from the Electronic Frontiers Foundation is basically calling to action, saying that Apple needs to stand up for their developers and defend them, because this isn't fair to let the developers kind of just flap around in the wind without helping them, considering that they know that those people can't defend themselves. Right. It's really funny to see an article where the EFF, you know, just I guess in this case, they're not really siding with Apple. It's more like they're trying to drive Apple to to do something.
不应该让他们使用，因为他们无法决定什么该发、什么不该发，这可能会成为一个问题。马克·扎克伯格说，看，这有点傻，他们已经在用了，我们应该允许他们使用，让他们学习如何使用。对我来说，这有点……即使文章标题也说这只是一个小争议，并不是什么大不了的事。但我认为提出这一点很有趣，因为当我们成长时，当我们还是孩子时，根本不用担心这种事，因为那种机会根本不存在。而现在我们必须考虑这个问题，如果我们有了孩子，我们要告诉他们怎么做？如果他们想
But, you know, the EFF practically hates Apple. It's more like they're trying to drive Apple to do something. But, you know, the EFF practically hates Apple, right? Yeah, that's true. So just to hear them talking about Apple, it's really a sentiment to Apple and just how pervasive Apple has become in this world, in the digital world. So talking about the way things are changing, you know, I saw an article saying that Markuckerberg wants to be able to let kids younger than 13 use facebook now currently you have to be the incredibly intelligent individual that has to understand that even if you're under 13 you can still just click the button that says you're over 13 and get on and so actually there's you know many reports out there showing that there are you know millions of people on facebook that are under 13 but it's technically not allowed like they're
上网，他们可以。所以我们要告诉他们：“看，你不准上去”？还是说，教他们如何正确使用并让他们上去？那么，多小才算太小？是的，这些都是非常好的问题，对吧？我认为这篇文章暗示的一点是，12岁孩子的 Facebook 界面会与成人的版本看起来非常不同。所以，只要有正确的家长监督，内置在控制功能中……是的，家长控制。是的，控制，甚至更多……我不知道那个词是什么，也许是“观察”，比如你可以看到你12岁的孩子点击过的所有个人资料之类的。那么是的，我觉得这会很棒。我的意思是，迪士尼已经这样做了，对吧？有几个迪士尼的大型多人在线游戏，比如《加勒比海盗》MMO，还有其他几个。我一时想不起来了。哦，是的，我见过。我看到过一个奇怪的卡通村庄之类的游戏。
not supposed to let them use that because they're not able to decide what should and shouldn't be posted there and it can just be a problem and mark zuckerberg saying that look this is kind of silly they're already doing it we should allow them to use it you know and learn about it and uh to me it's kind of uh you know even the article here in the title is like a minor controversy and it's not really that big a deal but i thought it was interesting to bring up that you know when we were growing up when we were kids you know there was no worry about this kind of thing because that opportunity didn't even exist really and uh that now we have to think about that you know if we're gonna have kids what are we gonna tell them to do like if they want to about that, you know, if we're going to have kids, what are we
我曾在电视上看到过一次广告。是的，是的，他们是13岁以下，需要家长同意之类的。当我在加州的迪士尼乐园时，他们有一个小演示，你可以跳上去玩。作为一个30岁的人，在一群12岁孩子中间跑来跑去，感觉有点诡异，所以我没玩太久就离开了。但我的意思是，环境就在那里，迪士尼在这方面取得了巨大的成功，我没听说过任何负面新闻。所以，只要你教你的孩子如何处理可疑或看起来不对劲的事情，或者知道在网上不要说某些话，我认为这很好。但有很多成年人还没弄清楚如何正确使用它，所以我不知道，我觉得有些孩子可能比许多成年人做得更好。但很难说，我想就像我说的，只要家长有选择观察的权利。这确实触及了……我的意思是，接着你刚才说的话，很多成年人真的不了解隐私，以及你在互联网上
going to tell them to do? Like if they want to get on Facebook, you know, they can. So are we going to tell them, look, you're not allowed to get on there? Or are you going to say, you know, teach them how to use it appropriately and let them get on? And then how young is too young? Yeah, I mean, these are all really good questions, right? I think that one of the things that this article hints at is that the facebook for a 12 year old will look very different from uh you know an adult the adult version of facebook and so you know as long as there's the correct parental supervision uh you know built into like controls yeah parental controls yeah controls and even more so uh i guess i don't know what the
拥有的隐私是多么少。有些人认为：“哦，如果我发布一些东西，只发给我的朋友，别人就看不到了。”我知道他们肯定知道别人只需要复制粘贴，就能发给全世界。但也许他们只是没想到会发生这种事。是的，人们甚至不了解互联网上事物的永久性。今天信息在世界中存在的方式非常不同。在印刷机出现之前，在书写之前，在录音出现之前，人们会说些什么。如果你没听到，它就成了传闻。它被口口相传。它非常短暂。但现在，你所做的一切都可以被记录，甚至这个播客也是，对吧？我们会录下这个。多年以后，在我们早就忘记做过这件事之后，我们的孩子可能还能在网上找到它，或者在某个地方看到它。它会被复制成千上万次，并以某种形式永远存在。所以你在 Facebook 上做的事情，即使你认为你删除了它们，就像你说的，别人可能已经在别处复制粘贴了，截了图，它被复制了。当维基解密发生时，你看到了这一点。撇开
word is observation maybe like maybe you can see all the profiles that your 12-year-old has clicked on or something like that. Then yeah, I think it would be great. I mean, Disney already does this, right? There's several Disney massively multiplayer games like the Pirates of the Caribbean MMO and there's a couple other ones. I can't think of them off the top of my head. Oh yeah, I've seen it. Some weird Cartoon Village one or something I saw off the top of my head. Oh, yeah, I've seen it. Some weird cartoon village one or something.
那件事是对是错不谈，仅仅是那些写信给维基解密说“请删除你拥有的那些不该有的机密文件”的人，这有什么意义呢？他能把 CD 退回来吗？我没法退回 CD，我当然可以从电脑上删除它，但它已经在 BitTorrent 上被成千上万的人复制了。从我的电脑上删除它并不能改变任何事情。是的，这非常真实。有段时间我经常使用 LiveJournal，我发布了一些关于……那不是冒犯性的，但非常陈腐，比如
I saw an advertisement on TV for once. Yeah, yeah, and so they're 13 and under and, you know, parental consent and things like that. And when I was at the Disneyland in California, they had a little demo where you could jump on and play. It was a little creepy being, like, 30 years old running around in this village with a bunch of 12 year olds so i wasn't on that game for too long without being weirded out and just
我讨厌某门课。哦，我真的不喜欢，我想是美国历史。很长一段时间里，如果你在谷歌上搜索我的名字，第一个链接就是“Jason Gauchi 讨厌美国历史”，这很容易追溯到我，确实是我。即使我在申请工作时，我也一直担心如果某个美国历史迷软件工程师面试我，那会很糟糕。所以这是真的。特别是正如这篇文章所指出的，如果你是一个12岁的孩子，你真的无法考虑你所说的话的永久性。大多数12岁的孩子没有那种成熟度。所以，是的，Facebook 会过得很艰难。但如果他们能创造一个安全、受监管且易于观察的环境，我认为这可能是一件积极的事情。
leaving but yeah no but i mean you know the environment's there and disney's had tremendous success with that and i haven't really heard of any bad press or anything so yeah i mean as long as if you you know show your kids the you know how to handle when something is suspicious or looks wrong or you know to not say certain things online that you know i think that's good but there's a lot of adults who haven't figured out how to use it appropriately so um i i don't know i think some kids could probably do a better job than many adults but yeah it's hard to say i guess like i said just as long as if maybe the parents have the option to be able to observe right and this really gets that sort of uh i mean just going off what you were saying a second ago a lot of adults really don't understand you know privacy and and really how
好的。我看到一篇文章说开源正在为学生准备更好的职业生涯。是的，我想这是一篇“废话”文章。是的，没错。但我认为这很有趣。我把它放进来是因为我知道你在开源项目上做了很多工作，并为此提供了帮助。总的来说，它谈到了学习如何沟通，学习如何在大项目中工作，以及如何规划。我的意思是，这些事情有点像“废话”。但我认为当你还在学校时，你有时间，
little privacy you have um on the internet you know some people think oh if i post something and uh i post it to my friends no one else will see it and you know i mean i'm sure they know that all someone has to do is copy and paste that you know and post it to the whole world but but maybe they just they don't think that something like that would happen you know yeah well i mean even people don't understand the permanency of things on the internet and it's kind of very different the way information exists in the world today. So, you know, it used to be before the printing press, before writing, you know, before recorded speech that people would say something. And if you didn't hear it, it became hearsay. It became passed down. Like it was
你以为你很忙，但其实并没有那么忙。所以如果学生们能花时间去加入一个开源项目并做出贡献，不仅仅是为了写在简历上，而是为了真正获得成长。这会让他们在开始第一份工作时准备得更充分，人们会注意到其中的差异，这也会帮助他们的职业生涯。没错。关于编程，它确实是一门艺术，我甚至会说它是一门手艺，类似于泥瓦匠之类的。但与共济会不同，那是一个高度秘密的组织，可能不再做泥瓦匠工作了。
very ephemeral. But then now and today, everything you do can be, you know, even this podcast, right? We'll record this. And then many years later, after we've long probably forgotten we've ever done this, our kids will probably be able to find this online somewhere floating around or posted somewhere. You know, it'll get copied thousands and thousands of times and it'll just live on forever in one form or another. You know, so things you do on Facebook, even if you think you delete them or get rid of them, like you said, somebody could have copied and pasted it somewhere else, taken a screenshot of it, you know, it gets duplicated. And you see this with things like WikiLeaks when that happened. And aside from, you know,
但与那些过去的秘密行业不同，在这种情况下，所有的信息、手艺和技能都可以在互联网上培养。但要做到这一点，你真的必须参与开源。所以，我们在这里谈论许多不同的编程语言，其中许多都有我们所说的“内置电池”，比如 Python 有内置的 Zlib 压缩。但是，你知道，许多语言，如 C++ 和 Java，这些你刚开始学习时接触的底层语言，并没有包含很多东西。所以你真的必须了解你手头有什么工具。比如，如果我想做加密，假设我
whether that was right or wrong, just the fact that some of the people, you know, writing to WikiLeaks and saying, can you please delete the copy of, you know, the stuff you have that you shouldn't have that that's classified, please delete it it's like what does it matter like he can't can you send us back it's like you know i can't send you back the cds i can sure i can delete it off of a computer it's been copied out on bit torrent to thousands of people like yeah leading off my computers isn't going to change anything yeah i mean it's extremely true there's a time when uh i was using live journal a lot and uh i was posting about something about it was something that was it wasn't offensive or anything but it was very trite like something
需要做某种加密哈希之类的，我知道几个开源工具，我会下载并真正知道哪些是好的，哪些是很难用的。那只是因为我参与过这么多不同的开源环境。你知道，你可以进入 Mozilla 的 Gecko 渲染引擎，进入 Mozilla 的 socket 代码，找出他们使用什么加密和 MD5 库。然后你可以访问他们的网站并深入研究。这有点像阅读研究论文。假设你对谷歌汽车非常感兴趣，那是完全开放的研究，对吧？自动驾驶汽车。你可以阅读那篇研究论文，它可能会使用很多我们都不懂的词汇。你可以去阅读那篇论文引用的论文，开始建立词汇量并理解发生了什么。
about i hated this particular class oh i really didn't like i think it was american history and for the longest time if you googled my name the first link was how you know adjacent gauchi which easily could have been traced to me and was me, hated American history. And even as I was applying for jobs and things like that, I had to carry around this fear that if some American history buff software engineer interviewed me, that it just wouldn't go over well. So it is true. Especially as this article draws our attention, if you're a 12-year-old, you really can't think about the permanency of what you say. Most 12-year-olds just don't have the maturity to do that. So, yeah, Facebook's going to have a tough time. But if they can create an environment that's safe and regulated and easily observable, I think that could be a positive thing.
以类似的方式，你可以深入研究一个开源项目，最终学到大量的编程知识，特别是关于如何完成工作，你可以给自己提供巨大的力量来开发一些惊人的应用程序。是的，我的意思是，很容易感到不知所措，即使你刚才说的那些东西也非常令人不知所措。但我的意思是，当你刚开始工作时，也会发生同样的事情，感觉有太多东西要学，我永远也弄不明白。但后来你做到了，你开始做出小的贡献，然后越来越大。有些开源项目可能比其他项目更适合这一点。有些项目……我不想说刻薄或敌对，但你知道，当你加入时，他们期望你已经知道很多东西，而另一些则更受欢迎。甚至这篇文章
All right. So I see an article here about open source preparing students for better careers. Yeah, I guess this is one of those no duh articles. Yeah, that's right. But I thought this was interesting. I put it in here because I know you've done a lot of work on open source projects and helped out with that. And, you know, in general, it talks about, you know, learning how to communicate, learning how to work on big projects and planning out with that. And, you know, in general, it talks about, you know, learning how to communicate, learning how to work on big projects and planning and all this. I mean, things that are kind of like, no, duh. But I think when you're in school, you have this time,
提到了谷歌编程之夏（Google Summer of Code），它是专门针对学生的。谷歌支付学生费用去从事开源项目。所以这些项目为学生设定了工作任务。是的，那些绝对很棒。我知道有几个人参加过。而且它非常容易参与。所以如果你真的进入了一个特定的开源社区，比如有一段时间我非常投入 Ogre 开源图形渲染引擎社区。你可以申请参加编程之夏。
but you kind of think you're busy, but you're not really all that busy. And so if students would take time to actually, you know, go join an open source project and actually make contributions, not just to put it on their resume, but to actually experience growth. It'll make them better prepared when they first start their first job, and people will notice there's a difference, and it'll help their careers. Right. I mean, the thing about, you know, programming is it really is an art, and it's almost, I guess I would say it's a trade, similar to like masonry and things like that. But unlike the Freemasons, which is a highly secretive society and probably doesn't do masonry anymore.
如果你有一个特别吸引人的项目。那些人通常非常乐于助人，他们想要……我的意思是，很多负责开源项目的人都是天生的领导者。我的意思是，Ogre 之所以成功，而 Joe Schmoe 的图形库不成功，是因为 Sinbad 和其他领导者
But unlike those, you know, secret trades of, you know, yesteryear. In this case, all of that information, that trade and that skill can be cultivated on the internet. But to do that, you really have to participate in open source. So, you know, we talk about many different programming languages here and a lot of them have, you know, as we talk about batteries included, like Python has a Zlib compression built into the language. But, you you know many languages like C++ and Java low-level the kind of languages you learn when you're first starting they don't have a lot included so you really have to sort of understand what are the tools at your disposal you know like if I want to do cryptography let's say if I
但与过去那些所谓的秘密交易不同，在这种情况下，所有的信息、交易和技能都可以在互联网上培养。但要做到这一点，你真的必须参与开源。所以，你知道，我们在这里谈论许多不同的编程语言，其中许多语言，正如我们所说的“内置电池”，比如 Python 在语言中内置了 Zlib 压缩。但是，你知道许多像 C++ 和 Java 这样的低级语言，也就是你刚开始学习时接触的那种语言，它们并没有包含很多东西，所以你真的必须了解你手头有哪些工具，比如如果我想做密码学，假设如果我
need to do some kind of cryptographic hashing or something, I know of several open source utilities and I would just download and actually know which ones are good and which ones are painful to work with. And that's just because I've been in so many different open source environments. You know, I've seen you can go into the Mozilla, you know, Gecko rendering engine and go into the socket code for Mozilla and find out what crypto and MD5 libraries they use. And then you can visit their websites and move it back. It's sort of like reading research papers. Let's say you're really interested in, you know, some kind of, let's say you're interested in the Google car, like that's all open research, right? The autonomous car. You can read that research paper and it'll probably use a bunch of words that none of us know. You can go and read the papers that are referenced by that paper and start to build the vocabulary and understand what's going on.
需要做某种加密哈希之类的东西，我知道几个开源工具，我会下载并真正知道哪些好用，哪些用起来很痛苦。这仅仅是因为我接触过太多不同的开源环境。你知道，我见过你可以进入 Mozilla 的 Gecko 渲染引擎，查看 Mozilla 的套接字代码，找出他们使用什么加密和 MD5 库。然后你可以访问他们的网站并将其移回。这有点像阅读研究论文。假设你对某种东西非常感兴趣，比如你对谷歌汽车感兴趣，那都是公开的研究，对吧？自动驾驶汽车。你可以阅读那篇研究论文，它可能会使用很多我们都不懂的词汇。你可以去阅读那篇论文引用的论文，开始建立词汇量并理解正在发生的事情。
You know, in a similar way, you can dive into an open source project and end up learning a tremendous amount about programming and especially about you know getting stuff done and you can give yourself a tremendous amount of power to do some amazing applications yeah and i mean i think it's very easy to get overwhelmed even the stuff you just said is very overwhelming but i mean that's the same thing that happens to you when you first start a job is it just seems like oh there's so much to learn i'm never going to figure it out but then you do and you start to make small contributions and bigger and bigger and some open source projects are are probably better suited to this than others some are you know kind of notoriously i don't want to say mean or hostile but you know kind of expect you to know a lot when you get there and others are more welcoming and um even this article
你知道，以类似的方式，你可以深入研究一个开源项目，最终学到大量的编程知识，尤其是关于如何完成工作，你可以赋予自己巨大的能力来开发一些令人惊叹的应用程序。是的，我的意思是，我认为很容易感到不知所措，即使是你刚才说的那些内容也非常令人不知所措，但我的意思是，这和你刚开始一份工作时发生的情况是一样的，看起来好像“哦，有太多东西要学了，我永远也弄不明白”，但后来你做到了，你开始做出小的贡献，然后越来越大。有些开源项目可能比其他项目更适合这一点，有些项目你知道，有点出了名的——我不想说刻薄或敌对，但你知道，当你到达那里时，他们期望你了解很多东西，而另一些项目则更受欢迎，而且嗯，即使是这篇文章
mentions the google summer of code which is specifically targeted at students. Google pays that student to work on the open source project. And so those projects create, you know, set tasks for the students to work on. Yep. Yeah, those are definitely awesome. I know several people have participated in that. And it's very accessible. So if you really get into a particular open source community, like there was a period of time where I was really involved in the Ogre open source graphics rendering engine community. And you can go and request to be part of the Summer of Code.
也提到了专门针对学生的谷歌编程之夏（Google Summer of Code）。谷歌支付报酬让学生参与开源项目。因此，这些项目会为学生创建并设定任务。是的。是的，这些绝对很棒。我认识几个人参加过那个项目。而且它非常容易上手。所以如果你真的进入了一个特定的开源社区，比如有一段时间我非常投入 Ogre 开源图形渲染引擎社区。你可以申请参加编程之夏。
And if you have a particular project, that's especially engaging. And those people are often very helpful and they want, you know, a lot of those people who are, you know, in charge of open source projects, they're natural leaders. I mean, the reason why Ogre is successful and Joe Schmoe's graphics library is not successful is because Sinbad and some of the other leaders
如果你有一个特别吸引人的项目。那些人通常非常有帮助，他们想要，你知道，很多负责开源项目的人，他们是天生的领导者。我的意思是，Ogre 之所以成功，而某个无名小卒的图形库不成功，是因为 Sinbad 和其他一些领导者
of that community are very charismatic. And they draw developers to go on there and work for free. So they will be more than happy to help you out and get you started. So yeah, definitely if you're in college, definitely take advantage of that. Yeah. So what is this hype animation creator? Yeah, so many of you out there probably have developed or done some stuff in Flash. If not, I'm sure everybody's used Flash. If you've ever watched a YouTube video, well now YouTube switched to HTML5, but regardless,
那个社区的人非常有魅力。他们吸引开发者去那里免费工作。所以他们会非常乐意帮助你，让你上手。所以，是的，如果你还在上大学，一定要利用好这一点。那么，这个 Hype 动画创建工具是什么呢？是的，你们很多人可能开发过 Flash 或者用它做过一些东西。如果没有，我相信每个人都用过 Flash。如果你看过 YouTube 视频，好吧，现在 YouTube 已经转向 HTML5 了，但无论如何，
many many applications out there on the internet. Websites have Flash embedded in them. But to do anything cool with Flash, you have to buy the Flash Studio. What's it called? It's Flash CS5 Professional, which is, I think it's like $2,000. And even, I remember as a student looking to get it, and it was several hundred dollars, even for the student edition. So, you know, and plus Flash, you know, has other issues as security vulnerabilities and, you know, it doesn't work on the iPhone. There's a hundred different reasons why making Flash stuff is kind of terrible. So what this hype says is we're going to try and give you the same, you know, functionality as Flash, but instead of the output being a Flash video, it's going to be HTML5 with the Canvas tag and the JavaScript, you know, WebGL rendering.
互联网上有非常非常多的应用程序。网站中嵌入了 Flash。但要用 Flash 做任何酷炫的事情，你必须购买 Flash Studio。它叫什么来着？是 Flash CS5 Professional，我想大概要 2000 美元。即使是作为学生，我记得当时想买它，即使是学生版也要几百美元。所以，你知道，而且 Flash 还有其他问题，比如安全漏洞，而且它在 iPhone 上无法运行。有上百个理由说明制作 Flash 内容是很糟糕的。所以这个 Hype 的意思是，我们要尝试给你提供和 Flash 一样的功能，但输出的不是 Flash 视频，而是带有 Canvas 标签和 JavaScript（你知道的，WebGL 渲染）的 HTML5。
So you get to the... Does it use WebGL or does it use the Canvas? So it uses Canvas now. They're looking at making it support WebGL, which would give it the hardware acceleration that Flash has. basically this hype is where flash you know was when it was 1.0 and it was saw software rendering etc but the cool thing about it is it looks the interface feels like the flash development environment so you have the keyframe animation you have the tweening where you say, you know, I want the object to be, you know, at position X at time zero and at position Y at time one, you know, and at time 0.5, it's the midpoint of X and Y.
所以你到了……它是使用 WebGL 还是使用 Canvas？它现在使用 Canvas。他们正在考虑让它支持 WebGL，这将赋予它 Flash 所拥有的硬件加速功能。基本上，这个 Hype 就像 Flash 1.0 时代一样，当时是软件渲染等等，但它最酷的地方在于，它的界面感觉就像 Flash 开发环境，所以你有关键帧动画，你有补间动画，你可以说，我想让对象在零时刻处于 X 位置，在 1 时刻处于 Y 位置，而在 0.5 时刻，它是 X 和 Y 的中点。
So it does the tweening, it does, you know, spline tweening so it can look smooth when things are moving around. All the cool things that Flash can do. And it generates something that you can see on virtually any device. Nice. And so this is a free program, a pay program? No, but it's relatively inexpensive. It says here it sells for $30. Okay.
所以它能做补间，它能做样条补间，这样当物体移动时看起来会很平滑。Flash 能做的所有酷炫事情它都能做。而且它生成的东西几乎可以在任何设备上看到。不错。那么这是一个免费程序，还是付费程序？不，但它相对便宜。这里说它售价 30 美元。好的。
So I haven't used it, but I'm thinking of buying it and trying it out. Yeah, well, I guess let us know how it works. It sounds kind of cool. Yeah, I think I i'm gonna buy it and uh if if it's good you'll see it as a as a tool of the buy week some weeks speaking of tool of the buy week yeah so uh so what's your tool of the buy oh you beat me to the punch what's your tool of the buy week this i guess I have to say my tool of the bye week is FileZilla, which has nothing in common with... That sounds like the thing that defeated Tokyo.
所以我还没用过，但我正考虑买一个试试。是的，好吧，我想让我们知道它效果如何。听起来挺酷的。是的，我想我会买它，如果它好用，你会在某几周的“本周工具”里看到它。说到“本周工具”，是的，那么你的“本周工具”是什么？哦，你抢先了，你的“本周工具”是什么？我想我得说我的“本周工具”是 FileZilla，它和……这听起来像是打败东京的那个东西。
Well, that was Godzilla. Yeah, FileZilla defeated, I don't know, Directoryville. I don't know. But FileZilla is not to be confused with Mozilla. I don't believe they have anything in common. I don't think the communities are in common or anything. FileZilla is not to be confused with Mozilla. I don't believe they have anything in common. I don't think the communities are in common or anything. FileZilla is an FTP client, but the UI is very slick. It has drag and drop from outside the window, so you can drag from Finder on a Mac or from
那是哥斯拉。是的，FileZilla 打败了，我不知道，Directoryville。我不知道。但 FileZilla 不要和 Mozilla 混淆。我不认为它们有什么共同点。我不认为它们的社区有什么共同点之类的。FileZilla 不要和 Mozilla 混淆。我不认为它们有什么共同点。我不认为它们的社区有什么共同点之类的。FileZilla 是一个 FTP 客户端，但它的用户界面非常简洁。它支持从窗口外拖放，所以你可以从 Mac 的 Finder 或
Explorer. You can just drag folders into the FTP server. It has a bunch of cool features you know you could do diffs you can actually open a text file on the ftp server and it'll open in your favorite editor and when you save and close the file filezilla somehow keeps track of the process when you've closed the editor it uploads the file back so it has a lot of nifty things and it's completely open source so you can put it on any computer you don't have to pay for it now filezilla is both an ftp server and an ftp client right oh did i say server uh i think you said you were saying client and you were talking about
Explorer 拖动。你可以直接把文件夹拖到 FTP 服务器里。它有很多很酷的功能，你知道你可以做差异比较，你实际上可以在 FTP 服务器上打开一个文本文件，它会在你最喜欢的编辑器中打开，当你保存并关闭文件时，FileZilla 会以某种方式跟踪这个过程，当你关闭编辑器时，它会把文件上传回去，所以它有很多巧妙的功能，而且它是完全开源的，你可以把它放在任何电脑上，不需要付费。现在，FileZilla 既是 FTP 服务器也是 FTP 客户端，对吧？哦，我说的是服务器吗？呃，我想你说的是客户端，你当时在谈论
yeah i don't think is it a oh yeah it is a server you know i've actually never used the filezilla server well just because that can be confusing when you go to the website. Because I've done that before, told people, oh, yeah, get FileZilla. And they're like, I don't need a server. I'm trying to connect to a server. Oh, that's interesting. Yeah, so I actually get it. You know, I'm a big, you know, Mac slash Ubuntu Linux fan.
是的，我不认为它是……哦，是的，它确实是一个服务器。你知道，我其实从来没用过 FileZilla Server。好吧，只是因为当你访问网站时这可能会让人困惑。因为我以前做过这种事，告诉别人，哦，是的，去下载 FileZilla。然后他们说，我不需要服务器。我是在尝试连接到服务器。哦，那很有趣。是的，所以我其实明白了。你知道，我是 Mac 和 Ubuntu Linux 的忠实粉丝。
And in Mac, you can get it through Mac ports. And in Ubuntu, you can get it through apt-get. So neither of which actually use the website. So I've never actually been on the website. It's my first time. But yeah, the FileZilla, it looks like the server is only for Windows, which is interesting.
在 Mac 上，你可以通过 Mac Ports 获取它。在 Ubuntu 上，你可以通过 apt-get 获取它。所以这两者其实都不用访问网站。所以我从来没真正上过那个网站。这是我第一次。但是的，FileZilla，看起来服务器端只支持 Windows，这很有趣。
Okay, yeah, yeah. But yeah, the client is very effective and I'd highly recommend it. One interesting thing too, it has like an auto-updater interface, which is pretty slick, even on Windows. You know, many of the open-source apps, and this is one thing that I've always had a problem with, and maybe if I have some more time, this is something I want to address, is you have NSYS, which is Nullsoft Scriptable Install System.
好的，是的，是的。但客户端非常有效，我强烈推荐它。还有一个有趣的地方，它有一个自动更新界面，非常简洁，即使在 Windows 上也是如此。你知道，许多开源应用程序，这是我一直以来遇到的一个问题，也许如果我有更多时间，这是我想解决的问题，就是你有 NSYS，也就是 Nullsoft Scriptable Install System。
So you know how you see like you download some open source program like filezilla for example and it has your stereotypical like here's a new license the GNU license in like a little install shield and you click next and it's like the directory install too you click yeah we talked about this last episode in association with over-the-air updates from apple and whether things are on the side or not. Yeah, we talked about it. So FileZilla actually has a nice auto-updater, and I just hope maybe I might lift it or something. So we'll see. Yeah.
所以你知道当你下载一些开源程序（比如 FileZilla）时，它会有那种典型的界面，比如“这是新的许可证，GNU 许可证”，在一个小小的安装向导里，你点击下一步，然后是安装目录，你点击……是的，我们上一集讨论过这个，关于苹果的无线更新，以及东西是否在侧边栏等等。是的，我们讨论过。所以 FileZilla 确实有一个不错的自动更新程序，我只是希望也许我可以借鉴一下之类的。所以我们走着瞧。是的。
So my tool of the bye week on the notion of, I guess, doing networking tasks is Putty, which is a Windows tool for doing remote connections to computers. So especially like SSH, Telnet, those kinds of things. It supports a whole host of things. There's actually a couple different programs to do various features like secure copying, SCP, and stuff like that. And this is kind of... So can I take this and put it on my walls to fix cracks and places where I've nailed
所以我的“本周工具”，关于网络任务的概念，是 Putty，这是一个用于远程连接电脑的 Windows 工具。所以特别是像 SSH、Telnet 之类的东西。它支持很多功能。实际上有几个不同的程序可以实现各种功能，比如安全复制（SCP）之类的。这有点……那么我可以拿这个贴在墙上来修复裂缝和钉子留下的洞吗？当然。我相信它可能对那个有用。它确实是一个非常有用的工具。但不行，我不会尝试用它来密封你房子里的任何裂缝。那可能不是个好主意。而且我也不会尝试把它贴在报纸的漫画上，让它像橡皮泥（Silly Putty）一样印上图像。
things to the wall? Sure. I'm sure it's probably good for that. It is a pretty useful tool. But no, I would not try to get it to seal any cracks in your house. That's probably not a good idea. And I also wouldn't try to stick it to a comic in the newspaper and make it have the image of it like Silly Putty.
抱歉。好的，无论如何，是的，但这个工具在 Windows 上连接 SSH 非常好用，它非常有用，因为我不认为 Windows 有原生的方式，它有一个原生的 Telnet 客户端，但没有原生的 SSH 客户端，所以这是每个人都在用的东西。它用起来有点让人困惑，因为它功能太多，太强大了，但一旦你弄明白了，它甚至可以设置代理隧道之类的东西，所以你可以通过它将 SSH 流量隧道传输到另一台电脑，并做各种有趣的事情。
Sorry. Okay. Anyways, yeah, but this tool is really good at connecting to ssh stuff on windows uh it's really useful for doing that because i don't think windows has a native way to even it has a native telnet client but not a native ssh client and so this is the thing everybody uses it's a little confusing to use because it does so much it's so powerful um but once you kind of figure it out it's able able to even do setting up proxy tunnels and stuff like that so you can tunnel SSH traffic through it to another computer and do all sorts of interesting things
像那样。所以它非常强大，但仅仅是能够在 Windows 上 SSH 连接某样东西的基本能力就非常好了。这是事实上的首选工具。所以那些第一次尝试做这件事的人，或者正在使用它的人，或者以前从未做过的人，如果他们不知道这个，他们会很快发现它，
like that. So it's really powerful, but just even the basic ability of just being able to SSH something on Windows is very nice. And this is the de facto thing to go to. And so people who are trying to do this for the first time or using it or have never done it before, if they don't know about this, they'll either quickly find it out
或者如果你告诉他们，他们会因为找到了它而非常兴奋。是的，是的，绝对。所以我想如果我没记错的话，有 Putty，它功能稍微全面一点。还有 Plink，对吧，来自同一家公司。我不知道，我想是的，好的，嗯，是的，他们确实有，看起来我看到了他们网站上的 Plink，所以是的，我想 Plink 更像是一个可脚本化的版本，它没有那么全面，但它算是一个
or if you tell them, they'll be really excited they found it. Yeah, yeah, definitely. So I think if I remember right, there's Putty, which is sort of a little bit more full-featured. There's also Plink, right, from the same company. I don't know i think yeah okay um yeah they do have it looks like it i see plink on here on their website so yeah i think plink is sort of more like a scriptable um version it's not as full-featured but it's sort of it's a
轻量级版本，我想是 Putty 的，但是的，它们都是适合任何 Windows 用户的优秀程序。是的，而且它是开源的，这很重要。每当你处理安全问题时，这总是一件有趣的事情，如果你有一个闭源的安全工具，例如 SSH 客户端，如果他们没有完全正确地实现所有功能，你可能会在认为安全的情况下被别人获取流量，所以至少开源的话，你知道，希望人们花时间审查过它，或者有机会审查它，对吧，并寻找漏洞。是的，所以今天，这个节目我们要讨论汇编。是的，就像流水线一样，是的，这有点像……你有没有在救济站做过社区服务？
lightweight version i guess of putty but yeah they're both excellent programs for anyone who's on Windows. Yeah, and it's open source and everything, which is important to note. Whenever you're dealing with security, it's always a kind of interesting thing that if you have a closed source security tool, for instance, like an SSH client, and they don't implement everything exactly right, you could be subject to people getting your traffic even when you think it's not so open source at least you know hopefully people have taken the time to review that or have the opportunity to review it right and look for vulnerabilities yeah so today uh this show we're going to be talking about assembly yeah and like assembly lines uh yeah it's kind of like uh have you ever had to do community service at the soup kitchen
然后有人走过来对你说，嘿，把 20 移到寄存器 3。下一个人走过来，你给他一些汤，他说，嘿，你知道，把 3 存到寄存器 5。这和那个很像，但它发生在电脑上。好的。那有点牵强。是的。但正如你所能看出的，正如你可能看出的，Patrick 绝对是汇编专家。而我大概一只手就能数出我见过汇编代码的次数。真的吗？哇。那有点可悲，Jason。是的。所以，是的。所以汇编，你知道，有点坚持我们的小格式，汇编的历史就是编程的历史，我想。
and, uh, someone comes up to you and they say, Hey, move a 20 to register three. And the next guy comes up to you and you give him some soup and he says, Hey, you know, store three and register five. It's similar to that, but it happens on the computer. Okay. That's a little bit of a stretch. Yeah. But as you could tell, as you could probably tell, Patrick is definitely the assembly expert. And I can probably count on one hand number of times I've seen assembly code. Really? Wow. That's kind of sad, Jason. Yeah. So, yeah. So assembly, you know, kind of sticking with our little format here, the history of assembly kind of is the history of programming, I guess.
当你第一次拥有一台只有 CPU 的电脑时，我们说的是，你必须以某种方式与它对话。必须有东西给它指令去执行。而这些指令不是 C，不是 Python，不是 Java，不是 Erlang。它们不是 C Sharp。是的，因为那些语言，正如我们过去讨论过的，比如 Python 运行在虚拟机上。但如果你想知道什么在实际的机器上运行，那就是汇编语言。嗯，其实也不完全是。所以这可能是一个细微差别，可能是一些非常具体的东西，
That when you first have a computer that has, you know, just a CPU we're talking, that you kind of have to talk to it somehow. Something has to give it instructions to execute. And those instructions aren't C, they aren't Python, they aren't Java, they aren't Erlang. They aren't C Sharp. Right, because those languages, as we talked about in the past, like Python runs on a virtual machine. But if you want to know what runs on the actual machine, it is assembly language. Well, actually, not quite. So this is maybe a nit, maybe something that's really specific
没人注意，只是语义问题。但汇编其实并不是直接在电脑上运行的东西。汇编甚至比那高出了一小步。所以真正运行在电脑上的东西被称为操作码（opcodes）。这就像原始的十六进制，一个数字，一个代表“移动”的十六进制数字，它将数据从一个寄存器移动到另一个寄存器，从 RAM 地址移动到寄存器，然后是一个对应于哪个寄存器的十六进制数字，以及一个十六进制地址。所以这基本上是人类无法阅读的。你根本读不懂。所以比那高一级的是汇编。它与所谓的助记符（mnemonics）有关，
and nobody pays attention, just it's semantic. But assembly actually isn't what runs on the computer directly. Assembly is even one step slightly above that. So the thing that actually runs on the computer are known as opcodes. So this is like raw hex, a number, a hex number that represents move, which moves from one register to another register, address and RAM to a register, and then a number that corresponds to a hex number that corresponds to which register and then a hex address. And so that's basically humanly not readable. You can't read that at all. So one step above that is assembly. And it kind of has to do with what's called mnemonics,
这有点像是为其他东西重新分配一个名字。所以你不需要记住必须输入 F-A 来表示移动，现在它可以只是字母 M-V 或 M-O-V，所以这是一个重命名。但它也允许你为寄存器设置特殊的名称，这样你就不必记住每个寄存器的十六进制代码之类的东西。但它确实引入了对所谓的“汇编器”（assembler）的实际需求，
which is kind of reassigning a name for something else. And so instead of having to remember that you have to type, you know, F-A for move, now it can just have the letters M-V or M-O-V, and so it's a renaming. But it also allows you to have special names for registers, so you don't have to remember the hex code for each register and things like that. But what that does introduce is the need for an actual, what's called an assembler,
这有点像编译器，但简单得多，因为即使在某些语言中，汇编器也可以是一次扫描而不是多次扫描，我们以前从未讨论过这一点。但高级语言的方式是，编译器可能必须对给定的源代码进行多次扫描才能弄清楚所有事情。而汇编器通常是一次扫描或两次扫描。它所做的是遍历代码，如果你使用了一个变量，它必须弄清楚那个变量将驻留在内存中的什么位置。它必须弄清楚寄存器名称是什么。
which is kind of like a compiler, but a lot simpler, in that even some languages, the assembler can be one pass instead of many passes, which we've never talked about that before. But the way that high level languages are, the compiler can have to make many passes through a given source code to try to figure everything out. And an assembler is typically either one pass or two pass. And what it does is it goes through and if you use a variable, it has to figure out where in memory that variable is going to reside. It has to figure out what the register names are.
它把所有这些东西转换成偏移量和数字。然后第二次扫描，它实际上做的是几乎像从指令到十六进制代码的音译。输入到 CPU 的指令，字面上告诉它如何引导某物通过流水线，通过 ALU，你知道，把东西从一个寄存器移动到另一个寄存器，做加法，做乘法，去 RAM 里取东西，处理所有这类事情。那么当你达到那个级别时，有哪些指令呢？比如一些典型的
And it kind of converts all of those things to offsets and to numbers. And then the second pass, it actually does almost like a transliteration just from the instruction to the hex code. The instructions that are fed into the CPU, which tell it literally how to guide something through the pipeline, through the ALU, you know, moving stuff from one register to another, to do an addition, to do a multiplication, to go fetch something out of RAM, to handle all of that kind of stuff. So what are a few instructions when you get down to that level? Like what are some typical
指令是什么？所以典型的指令……我的意思是，你能做类似排序列表的事情吗？它就像调用一个函数，你做一堆事情，或者……嗯，不，但有时，这是汇编的一个非常独特的怪癖。所以当你谈论高级语言时，汇编是某种最低级的语言（不包括没人做的操作码编程），所以汇编器是最低级的，然后你向上走到 C，然后到 C++，上面还有一些东西，也许是 Java 或 Python。所以当你沿着那个堆栈向上移动时，你获得的是可移植性，也就是当我们谈论在虚拟机上运行时，你不需要关心你在什么 CPU 上运行。
instructions? So typical instructions... I mean, could you do like is can you do like sort a list is it like calling a function where you do a bunch of things or well so no but sometimes and this is a very unique quirk of uh of assembly so when you talk about higher level languages which assembly is kind of the lowest level language you know excluding opcode programming which nobody does so assembler but is the lowest and you kind of go up to like c and then to c plus plus and there's something above that maybe java or python um and so when you move up that stack you're gaining portability which is the ability like when we talk about running on a virtual machine that you don't care about what cpu you're running on
但汇编指令有趣的地方在于，它们对于给定的处理器是完全唯一的。所以如果你正在使用 x86 Intel 处理器，然后你尝试去一台有不同处理器的机器上运行。所以你知道，Macintosh 电脑过去运行在 Power PC 上，旧电脑可能运行在 Alpha 处理器上，甚至像 Android 手机使用的是 ARM 处理器，实际上 iPhone 也是如此，使用 ARM 处理器。所有这些处理器都有完全不同的指令集，所以汇编语言和支持的指令可能会在这些处理器之间有很大差异。例如，在一个处理器上，执行指令的方式，如果你说有一个移动指令，你想从一个
but the interesting thing with assembly instructions is that they are completely unique to a given processor. So if you're using, you know, an x86 Intel processor, and then you try to go run on a machine that has something different. So you know, Macintosh computers used to run on power PCs, older computers might run on alpha processors or even like the android phones are using arm processors and actually the iphone does as well uses an arm processor those all those processors have different completely different instruction sets and so the assembly language and the the routine supported the instruction supported can vary greatly between those. For instance, that on one, the way that an instruction is done, if you say have a move and you want to move from one
寄存器移动到另一个寄存器，你可能会先列出源寄存器，然后是目标寄存器。而在另一个处理器上，它可能是相反的，先是目标寄存器，然后是源寄存器。哦，我明白了。所以你必须小心。而且指令的数量和复杂性也可能不同。所以这必须涉及到所谓的 CISC 和 RISC 之间的区别。CISC 是 C-I-S-C，即复杂指令集计算机。而 RISC 是精简指令集计算机。所以最初的 CPU 非常基础，
register to another register, you may list the, you know, origin register first and the destination register second. And then in another processor, it may be reversed, where it's the destination register first and the source register second. Oh, I see. So you've got to be careful. And then also the number and, you know, complexity of the instructions can vary. So that has to come with something called the difference between CISC and RISC. And CISC is a C-I-S-C, which is complex instruction set computer. And then a RISC is a reduced instruction set computer. And so originally the CPUs were very basic
从定义上讲属于 RISC，但它们当时不叫这个名字，因为没有替代品。它们只能支持很少的指令。然后随着它们的发展，它们变得更加复杂以支持各种功能。甚至像你刚才说的，你可能有一个单一的汇编指令，
and kind of were RISC by definition, but they weren't called that because there was no alternative. They could only support very few instructions. And then as they grew, they become more complicated to support things. Even like you were talking about, like you may have a single assembly instruction
允许你对一个数组或八个数字的数组进行排序，它现在可以在一条指令中完成。那条指令可能需要多个周期来执行，但你可以有一条汇编指令来完成它，而且它会非常优化，因为它在那一点上不是用软件实现的，硬件实际上实现了那个排序。没错，所以也许我们应该谈谈，因为这与本节目特别相关，寄存器和内存之间的区别。我不认为我们解释过那个。不，是的，这是一个好点。所以，你想试着解释一下，还是让我来？我会试一下，然后也许你可以补充。好的，你来吧。我对底层不太擅长，但基本上据我所知，你知道每个人都知道
that allows you to sort an array or an array of like eight numbers and it can do it in one instruction now that instruction may take many cycles to execute but you can have one assembly instruction that does that and it's going to be very optimized because it's not implemented in software at that point the hardware actually implements that sorting and that's right so maybe we should talk a little bit about since it's particularly relevant to this this show the difference between registers and memory i don't think we've ever explained that no yeah that's a good point so uh do you want to take a shot at that or you want me to go i'll give it a shot and then maybe you can clean up yeah go ahead yeah i'm not too good at the low level but so basically from what i understand uh you know everyone knows
主内存，所以你有，你知道，你去 Best Buy 商店，你说，我想要一台有 4G 内存的电脑。所以你最终得到了一组 4GB 的内存。而且，你知道，应用程序被分配了所谓的地址空间，你知道，在那 4GB 内存里的受保护地址空间。所以当你启动 Microsoft Office 之类的程序时，你知道，操作系统（在这种情况下是 Windows）会给 Office 分配一定量的内存。你可以拥有这 128MB 的块，比如说。所以 Microsoft Office 可以进入那块内存，分配、释放内存，把数字放进去，把你的 Excel 电子表格放进去等等。
about main memory so you have you know you go to the store to Best Buy and you say, I want a computer with four gigs of RAM. So you end up with, you know, a bank of four gigabytes. And, you know, applications are given what's called an address space, you know, protected address space inside of that four gigabytes. So when you start Microsoft Office or something, you know, the operating system, in this case Windows, gives Office a certain amount of memory. You can have this block of 128 megs, let's say. And so Microsoft Office can go in that memory and allocate, deallocate memory, and put numbers in there and put your Excel spreadsheet in there, etc.
现在，电脑，CPU，它坐在你主板上的芯片里。而且，就主板而言，它离内存非常非常远。所以内存，它需要花费惊人的时间，比如毫秒级的，才能把数据从内存传送到处理器。或者也许比那更快，比如微秒之类的。但处理器本身可以在纳秒级运行。所以处理器需要能够非常快速地查看数据并将数据放入某些地方的能力，比内存所能支持的速度快得多。
Now, the computer, the CPU, it's sitting on a chip on your motherboard. And it's, you know, in terms of the motherboard, it's far, far away from the memory. So the memory is, it takes an incredible amount of time, like on the order of milliseconds to get data from the memory to the processor. Or maybe it's faster than that, like microseconds or something. But the processor itself can run in terms of nanoseconds. So the processor needs the ability to sort of look at data and put data into places very quickly, much faster than the memory can support.
所以有一些东西叫做寄存器，它们就坐在处理器旁边。实际上就在处理器里，紧挨着逻辑单元。所以负责将两个数字相加的单元，紧挨着它，有一个小的存储库，通常比如说 10 到 20 个寄存器，可以保存即将被立即使用的东西。是的，那是为了，你知道，一些可能需要很长时间才能解释的东西。这是一个非常好的解释，它被谈论为内存层次结构，所以你可以把它想象成一个金字塔。所以就像你指出的 RAM，你有 GB 的 RAM，但然后是一个进程
So there are things called registers, which are sitting right next to the processor. So actually in the processor right next to the logic unit. So the units that are responsible for adding two numbers, right next to that, there's a small bank, usually let's say 10 to 20, you know, registers that can hold things which are going to be used immediately yeah that was for you know something that could take a very long time to explain that's a really good explanation and it's kind of talked about as memory hierarchy so you can kind of imagine it like a pyramid so like you were pointing out ram you have gigabytes of ram um but then a process
寄存器，你可能只有像你说的 32 个，它们通常是 2 的幂，比如 16 或 32 个寄存器，每一个都只持有一个单一的……如果你有一台 32 位电脑，它会持有一个单一的 32 位数字，或者如果你有一台 64 位电脑，它会持有一个 64 位数字，这就是那些“32 位处理器”、“64 位处理器”的由来，就是它处理的原生数据大小。所以层次结构是，靠近 CPU 的是非常非常有限的内存，所以你可能有 32 个数字，然后当你向上走时，你会经过所谓的缓存（cache），它稍微大一点，稍微远一点，你继续向外走，一直走到主内存，然后到硬盘，这确实需要（你知道）毫秒级的时间来访问。如果你考虑……你知道，你说它很远，这是一个在我学习计算机架构时帮助过我的比喻，
registers you may only have like you said 32 they're normally in powers of two so like 16 or 32 registers and each one of those only holds a single if you have a 32-bit computer it'll hold a single 32-bit number or if you have a 64-bit computer it'll hold a 64-bit number and that's where those a 32-bit processor 64-bit processor that's where that comes from is what the size of the native amount that it works with is and then so the hierarchy is that close to the CPU it's very very limited memory so you may have 32 numbers and then as you go up you go through something called cache which is a little bit bigger and a little bit farther away and you keep going out all the way out to main memory and then to the hard disk which does take you know milliseconds to access and if you think about um you know you say it's far away and and this was an illustration that helped me when i was learning about computer
但是，今天的处理器运行在几个 GHz。如果你考虑 1GHz 的频率在一个周期内。所以那个 GHz 衡量的是电脑的时钟每秒跳动多少次。所以 1GHz 的电脑是……什么是 Giga？是十亿，因为 MHz 是百万，然后 Giga 是十亿。所以它在一秒钟内计数十亿次。
architecture but um the processor today run at a couple gigahertz and if you think about uh the frequency of one gigahertz in one cycle. So that gigahertz measures how many times the computer's clock ticks up and down per second. So a one gigahertz computer is, what's giga is a billion, because a megahertz is a million, and then a giga is a billion. So a billion times in one second, it counts.
所以在每一次计数之间，如果你真的观察光在一个周期内能走多远，它只相当于（你知道）大约手臂的宽度。所以如果你举起双臂，让它们保持肩宽左右，或者无论多少，那大约就是光在一个周期内能走的距离，这并不远。所以几英尺，对吧？所以即使板子上的东西，你说，哦，它们只有几英寸远，好吧，是的，但我们谈论的是速度，快到即使在一个时钟周期内，你也不能走到主内存再及时回来。没错。所以记住 Patrick 的比喻与光有关，但在这种情况下，我们处理的是电，而电的速度
And so between each of those counts, if you actually look at how far light can travel in one cycle it only amounts to you know about uh you know arms width so if you raise your arms up and hold them about shoulder width apart or whatever that's about how far light can travel in one cycle which is not very far so a couple feet right and so even though the things on the board you say oh they're only a couple inches apart well yeah but we're talking about speed so fast that even in one clock cycle you cannot go out to main memory and get back in time right so remember patrick's analogy has to do with light but in this case we're dealing with electricity and the speed of
要慢得多。没错。而且它不是直接连接。实际上，如果你考虑它必须走多远，在处理器和主内存之间就像一个迷宫。它不是一条直线。没错。而且两者之间有一个控制器，一个内存控制器。它非常复杂。
electricity is significantly slower that's right that right. And it isn't a direct connection. There's actually, if you think about how far it has to travel, it's like a veritable maze between the process, where you are in the process or all the way out to main memory. It's not a straight line. Right. And there's a controller, a memory controller in between the two. It's very complicated.
是的。所以，是的。所以寄存器，就像你说的，有一组存储单元，每个单元各存一个数字。当你编写汇编指令时，你明确地操作这些寄存器。所以 RISC 和 CISC 之间的区别之一是，在 RISC 中，例如，它只允许你从两个寄存器中获取数据进行乘法，然后放入另一个寄存器。所以乘法、加法、减法、
Yeah. So, yeah. So the registers, like you said, there's a bank of holding cells of one number each in each one. And you explicitly operate on those when you write an assembly instruction. And so one of the differences between RISC and CISC is that in a RISC, for instance, it will only allow you to do multiplication taking from two registers and putting into another register. So multiplications, additions, subtractions,
除法只能在寄存器到寄存器的基础上完成，你不能去主内存。然后你有……所以你有那些基本的指令，你还有所谓的“加载和存储”（load and store）。所以加载（load）意味着去主内存，把它带到一个寄存器地址。而存储（store）意味着把寄存器里的东西拿出来，放到主内存里。那些指令可以在寄存器之外操作。然后你可以有类似“移动”（move）的指令，你可能需要从一个寄存器移动到另一个寄存器。所以本质上是从一个复制到另一个。所以这谈论的是数据内存。还有一些你必须意识到的东西，即程序内存，程序数据，
you know, divisions can only be done on register to register basis, you cannot go out to main memory. And then you have so you have those kind of basic instructions, you also have what's called a load in store. So a load says go out to main memory and bring it into a register address. And a store says take something that's in a register and stick it out to main memory. And those ones can operate outside of registers. And then you can have something that says move, where you might need to move from one register to another register. So essentially do a copy from one to another. So that's kind of talking about data memory. There's also something that you have to be aware of, which is program memory, program data,
也就是正在执行的指令。所以有两种，根据你的机器，有两种可以放在一起，也可以分开，但有两种数据，一种是你操作的数据。然后是指令。所以指令也必须输入到电脑中。所以这就是，你有一个指令指针（instruction pointer），它是 RAM 中当前正在执行的汇编指令、当前操作码所持有的地址。所以在 32 位机器上，那些通常，你知道，32 位被划分为操作码是什么、寄存器是什么、源寄存器是什么、目标寄存器是什么。所以当 CPU 加载该指令时，它必须知道如何处理指令
which is the instructions that are executing. So there's kind of two, and depending on your machine, there's kind of two can be together, it can be separate, but there's two kinds of data, there's data that you operate on. And then there's the instructions. And so the instructions have to be fed into the computer as well. And so what that is, is you have an instruction pointer, which is the address in RAM that the current assembly instruction you're executing, the current opcodes are held. So on a 32-bit machine, those normally, you know, that's 32 bits is divided up between what the opcode is, what a register is, and what the source register is, what the destination register is. And so when the CPU loads that instruction, it then has to know what to do with the instruction
指针。所以如果它只是一个移动、加载、存储或加法，它所做的只是将指令指针增加该指令的大小。所以只是跳转到下一条指令。但这不支持任何条件判断。所以如果你只有那些指令，你将永远无法做任何不同的事情。你的程序将是完全确定性的。你启动它，它总是做完全相同的事情，没有任何改变。
pointer. And so if it's, for instance, just a move or a load or a store or an add, what it'll do is just increment the instruction pointer by the size of that instruction. And so just kind of go to the next instruction. But that doesn't support any sort of conditional stuff. So if you just had those instructions, you would never be able to do anything different. Your program would be completely deterministic. You would just start it and always would do exactly the same thing and nothing would ever change.
那会非常无聊。没错。我的意思是，我们知道当我们编写 C 代码或任何其他语言时，代码中有一些部分我们在运行时会执行或不会执行。所以我们可能会说，如果某个变量大于 20，那么执行这段代码。否则，它将跳过那段代码。所以当这些语言，高级语言，被编译成汇编时，那对应于一个跳转（jump）。没错。
And that would be really boring. Right. I mean, we know that when we write C code or any other language, that there are sections of the code that we do or don't step through at runtime. So we might say, if some variable is greater than 20, then do this code. Otherwise, it's going to skip that block of code. And so when these languages, higher-level languages, get compiled down to assembly, that corresponds to a jump. That's right.
嗯，其实，是的，取决于它，有几种不同的东西。但一种可能是跳转。没错，嗯，实际上，是的，取决于它，有几种其他的东西，但一种可能是跳转。所以跳转就像是去往另一个不是下一条指令的指令，所以你可以跳转到一个不同的地址。这就是汇编器比纯操作码编程更有帮助的地方，那个跳转可以去往你文件、源代码中的一个标签，编译器、汇编器稍后将能够弄清楚那个地址是什么。如果你必须手动完成，你将不得不计算在跳转中要跳过多少字节。
Well, actually, yeah, depending on it, there's a couple different things. But one could be a jump that's right well uh actually there's yeah depending on there's a couple other things but one could be a jump so a jump would be like a go to another instruction that isn't the next instruction so you could jump to a different address and that's where the assembler helps versus writing in pure opcodes is that that jump can go to a label in the computer in the in your file in your source code which the the compiler, the assembler, will be able to figure out what that address is later. If you had to do it by hand, you would have to calculate how many bytes to skip in your jump.
那会让人困惑和烦人。如果你添加了一行新代码，你将不得不更改所有这些数字。没错。所以汇编器为你做了这些工作。但其他东西，有时它们被称为跳转。另一件事是分支（branch）。所以跳转通常总是完成的，你总是跳转到一个新的位置。没错。所以跳转的一个例子会
And that would be confusing and annoying. And if you added a new line, you'd have to change all of those numbers. That's right. So the assembler does that work for you. But other things, so sometimes they're called jumps. The other thing is a branch. So a jump is kind of always done you always jump to a new location right so an example of a jump would
是像返回（return），在 C 中对应于返回的一部分。是的，是的，没错。所以如果你有一个 void 函数并且你要返回，那只是一个跳转。没错，它会跳转……这实际上很让人困惑，我们现在先忽略它。但是的，所以跳转只是去那里。无论你告诉它什么地址，它就从那里开始，它将指令指针更改为那个新地址，并从那一点开始拾取并开始运行。另一个选择是分支。所以分支基本上，就像这个词所暗示的，
be like a return and c corresponds to a jump part of a return yeah yeah that's right so like if you had a void function and you're returning that would just be a jump yep and it would jump that actually like it's confusing we'll ignore that for now But yeah, so a jump just kind of goes there. Wherever you tell it an address and it just picks up, it changes the instruction pointer to that new address and picks up from that point and just starts going. The other option is a branch. And so a branch basically, like the word implies,
采取两条路径之一。而这两条路径通常基于某种条件。所以你可以有“相等则分支”、“不为零则分支”、“为零则分支”这类指令。根据你的处理器，取决于你有什么。但例如，如果你说“不为零则分支”，那么你可以做的是，之前你可以有一些东西来评估一个给定的数字，你可能会做一个减法。如果那个减法不是零，或者如果你有大于零的东西，那么它会设置一个寄存器来拥有一个值，
takes one of two paths. And those two paths are normally based on some sort of conditional. So you could have branch if equal, branch if not zero, branch if zero, these kind of instructions. And depending on your processor will depend on what you have. But for instance, if you say branch if not zero, then what you can do is previously you can have something that evaluates whether or not a given number, you might do a subtraction. And if that subtraction isn't zero, or if you have something that's greater than zero, then it sets a register to have a value
你将根据它来判断。当你执行“相等则分支”或“不相等则分支”或“为零则分支”时，它会去查看那个寄存器。它说，这个寄存器符合我的标准吗？如果是，那么我就去下一条指令；如果不是，那么我就去分支并跳转到代码的其他部分。这相当于你之前说的 if 块，所以如果（你知道）如果为真，那么执行这个块里的内容，所以它只是继续执行下一条指令；但如果不是，它需要跳过那个块并从其他地方开始。所以这些构成了你拥有的基本指令，这看起来非常简单，几乎就像……我不知道你怎么样，但我第一次
that you're going to key off of. And when you say branch, if equal or branch, if not equal or branch of zero, then it goes and looks at that register. And it says, does this register meet my criteria? If so, then I just go to the next instruction if it doesn't then i'm going to go branch and do a jump to some other portion of code and that amounts to like you were saying before the if block so if you know if true right then execute what's in this block so it's just going to keep going to the next instruction but if not it needs to skip over that block and pick up somewhere else and so those kind of make up the basic instructions that you have and it seems really simple almost like you know I don't know about you but the first
学习二进制时，它对我来说没有意义，你可以在二进制中表示每个数字，对吧？就像，不，你不能做每个数字，一定有一些数字你做不到。然后慢慢地你意识到，等等，你可以做每个数字。所以汇编也是一样，当你学习它时，实际上有理论上证明过的电脑只有一条指令，你就可以编写每一台可能的电脑。它被称为图灵完备（turing complete），基本上你能够证明你可以用只有一种指令编写每一个可能的程序。但这不一定有效或最好的方式，但它是可以做到的。
time I learned binary it was like didn't make sense to me that you could represent every number in binary right it's like no you can't do every number there's got to be some number you can't do and then slowly it dawns on you wait you can do every number so assembly is kind of the same way where when you learn it there are actually computers that have been theoretically proven that only have one instruction and you could write every possible computer it's called turing complete that basically you're able to prove that you can write every possible program with just one kind of instruction but that's not necessarily efficient or the best way, but it can be done.
所以用非常非常少的指令，你可以构建我们在高级语言中拥有的所有复杂的东西。是的，我的意思是，想想，你知道，Java，你知道，我想是虚拟机。所以换句话说，如果你正在为 Java 机器编写本质上的汇编代码，它只有一个堆栈，它甚至没有寄存器，它只有一个堆栈。所以我猜在某种意义上它有无限的寄存器，但基本上你一次只能看一个寄存器。是的，所以它能够做任何你可以在 Java 中编码的事情，正如我们之前讨论过的，你知道，几乎任何事情。你在电脑上看到的任何东西都可以用 Java 完成。所有这些设计选择都有权衡。工程学就是关于权衡的，它是关于理解
And so with very, very few instructions, you can build all the complex things that we have in our high-level languages. Yeah, I mean, just think, you know, the Java, you know, I guess virtual machine. So in other words, if you're writing essentially assembly code for the the java machine just has a stack it doesn't even have registers it just has a single stack so i guess in a sense it has infinite registers but basically you can only look at one register at a time yeah so and that is able to do anything that you can code in java which is as we've talked about before which is you know just just about anything yeah that you've seen on the computer can be done in java and all of those design choices have trades with them engineering is all about making trades it's about understanding
没有一个唯一的正确答案，它是关于理解你所做的选择。编程 Throwdown 的一部分，我们试图做的是说，有所有这些不同的语言，它们都有各自的优点和缺点，帮助你更好地理解这些是什么，并帮助你做出明智的选择。所以，例如，CISC 和 RISC 之间的区别，你可能会说，好吧，为什么会有精简指令集？为什么不是每个人都提供尽可能多的指令并使它们非常高效。但当你这样做时，你的处理器变得更加复杂。而且处理器进行某些优化也更难，如果它是 RISC，而不是花费所有那些额外的晶体管
there's no one right answer that it's about understanding the choices you make and part of programming throwdown what we're trying to do is say that there's all these different languages and they all have their advantages and disadvantages and help you understand better what those are and help you make the intelligent choice. So, for instance, the difference between CISC and RISC, you might say, well, why is there a reduced instruction set? Why doesn't everybody just provide as many instructions as possible and make them really efficient. But when you do that, your processor becomes more complex. And it's also harder for the processor to do certain optimizations where if it's risk, instead of spending all those extra transistors
试图实现这些复杂的指令，你可以让它更聪明。所以取几条指令并更智能地使用它们，做一些类似重新排序之类的事情。所以这些都是所做的权衡。是的。
trying to implement these complex instructions, you can have it be smarter. So take a few instructions and work with them more intelligently and do things like reordering them and stuff like that. And so these are all trade-offs that get made. Yeah.
我的意思是，如果你能，你知道，收紧你对指令的期望范围。所以换句话说，如果你的指令之一，正如 Patrick 早些时候所说，是对列表进行排序，那可能需要很长时间。该指令的范围可能需要从一纳秒到 300 纳秒。而与 RISC 处理器相比，你可以明确地说，你知道，每条指令将需要一到，比如说，20 纳秒。所以如果你能收紧这些范围，那么你就能更好地预测未来会是什么样子。而预测是使汇编、使……的关键。
I mean, if you can, you know, tighten the bounds on your expectations for, you know, for your instructions. So in other words, if one of your instructions, as Patrick said earlier, is to sort a list, that might take a long time. The bounds on that instruction might take anywhere from a nanosecond to 300 nanoseconds. And versus a risk processor where you could say definitively, you know, every instruction is going to take one to, let's say, 20 nanoseconds. And so if you can tighten those bounds, then you can better predict what the future is going to look like. And prediction is key to making assembly, to making,
我的意思是，如果你能，你知道，收紧你对指令的预期范围。换句话说，如果你的指令之一，正如 Patrick 之前所说，是排序一个列表，那可能需要很长时间。该指令的范围可能需要 1 纳秒到 300 纳秒不等。而与精简指令集（RISC）处理器相比，你可以明确地说，你知道，每条指令将需要 1 到 20 纳秒。因此，如果你能收紧这些范围，那么你就能更好地预测未来会是什么样子。而预测是实现汇编、实现的关键，
you know, CPUs run faster. That's right. That's right. And we could talk endlessly about this. I mean, understanding assembly is understanding computer architecture. And understanding computer architecture, I believe, is key to writing efficient code. And you got to know the system you're working on. If you don't know the system you're working on, even if't know the system you're working on even if no matter what language you're writing in you're not going to write the most efficient code and you don't always have to write the most efficient code but if you kind of take a few minutes to understand what you're working with it's going to help you avoid you know doing grossly unnecessary things that are very inefficient right so what are what are
你知道，CPU 运行得更快。没错。没错。我们可以无休止地谈论这个。我的意思是，理解汇编就是理解计算机体系结构。我相信，理解计算机体系结构是编写高效代码的关键。你必须了解你所使用的系统。如果你不了解你所使用的系统，无论你使用什么语言编写代码，你都不会写出最高效的代码。虽然你不一定非要写出最高效的代码，但如果你花几分钟时间去了解你所使用的东西，这将有助于你避免做一些非常低效且完全没必要的事情，对吧？那么，有哪些
some uses of when have you used assembly language? So kind of the first place I learned it was in school when I was at the university. And they talked, when we used embedded processors, so kind of digital signal processors, and they often don't have an operating system, don't have even something like C needs a library of code to be able to call for functions like printf or what does a for loop really do? And they rely on helper functions. So these don't have those. And so you have to write an assembly. So we use assembly to be able to program those.
汇编语言的使用场景呢？我第一次接触它是在大学的时候。当时我们使用嵌入式处理器，比如数字信号处理器，它们通常没有操作系统，甚至连 C 语言这样需要代码库来调用 printf 等函数的东西都没有，或者说 for 循环到底是怎么实现的？它们依赖于辅助函数。而这些处理器没有这些功能，所以你必须用汇编语言来编写。因此，我们使用汇编语言来对它们进行编程。
We also had to learn how to design our own CPUs and design our own assembly language. And of course we programmed those in assembly. Actually, we programmed those in pure op codes like we were talking about. Oh, wow. That's one use. And that really helps you understand what's going on. And that's pretty cool, but it's a lot of work.
我们还必须学习如何设计自己的 CPU 和汇编语言。当然，我们是用汇编语言来编写它们的程序。实际上，我们是用纯操作码（op codes）来编写的，就像我们刚才谈到的那样。哦，哇。这是一种用途。这确实能帮你理解底层发生了什么。这很酷，但工作量很大。
It's kind of scary. So, but kind of in the real world, that's still used today. Even with all the advances, there are still times when you have to use assembly because there's nothing else to use. Right. And just think, you know, right now, as Patrick was saying, we have the ARM processor, which is actually the ARM processor is quite old. But you can imagine as new processors come out, somebody has to write the assembly language, you know, assembler for those processors, and that person is writing in straight opcodes.
这有点吓人。不过，在现实世界中，它今天仍然被使用。即使有了所有的进步，仍然有些时候你必须使用汇编语言，因为没有其他选择。没错。试想一下，正如 Patrick 所说，我们现在有 ARM 处理器，实际上 ARM 处理器已经很老了。但你可以想象，随着新处理器的推出，必须有人为这些处理器编写汇编语言，也就是汇编器，而那个人就是在直接编写操作码。
That's right. That's right. And so that's kind of one option. The other reason to use it is, you know, if you want to squeeze every bit of performance out of a system, you typically will use assembly. And so one of the paradigms is important is to not optimize too early. But once you've determined this code is executed, you know, a million times every frame of my game, let's say, I got to do this one thing a million times. Then you want to go in and say that's slowing my system up because it's taking too long. You can go in and write that specific routine and assembly and make it just blazing fast
没错。没错。所以这是一种选择。使用它的另一个原因是，如果你想榨干系统的每一分性能，你通常会使用汇编语言。其中一个重要的范式是不要过早优化。但一旦你确定这段代码在我的游戏中每一帧都要执行一百万次，比如说，我必须把这一件事做一百万次。那么你就会想要进去说，因为它太慢了，导致我的系统变慢了。你可以进去用汇编语言编写那个特定的例程，让它变得快如闪电。
because you're going to do things as efficiently as possible. Because, for instance, instead of going out to memory, you can say, hey, how do I use my registers more effectively than maybe the compiler is able to do? Because the compiler is working at a much higher level, has a lot more things to do, and it can't be perfectly efficient all the time. Right.
因为你会尽可能高效地完成任务。例如，与其去访问内存，你可以说，嘿，我该如何比编译器更有效地利用我的寄存器呢？因为编译器是在更高的层面上工作，它有更多的事情要做，不可能总是做到完美高效。没错。
Another thing is if you need precise timing. So if you need to know exactly how long something's going to take, you oftentimes will write it in assembly. And then we talked last week about reverse engineering. And we talked about how that if you write something in C, compile it, that's a lossy operation. That going the other way isn't going to get you back to exactly where you started. And so what one thing you can do is even if you've compiled stuff in C or C++, or even, for instance, compiled it into Java bytecode and reverse engineer that, if you actually look at those opcodes that were generated and write the assembly for that, without going to a higher level language, which is going to be more confusing in some ways,
另一件事是如果你需要精确的计时。所以如果你需要确切地知道某件事需要多长时间，你通常会用汇编语言编写它。我们上周谈到了逆向工程。我们谈到如果你用 C 语言编写代码并编译它，那是一个有损操作。反向操作并不能让你回到最初的状态。所以你可以做的一件事是，即使你已经用 C 或 C++ 编译了东西，或者甚至编译成了 Java 字节码并对其进行逆向工程，如果你查看生成的那些操作码并为其编写汇编代码，而不需要回到更高级的语言（这在某些方面会更令人困惑），
you can look at what the actual instructions that were generated were and begin to recover what the structure was what was it doing what how was it accessing memory in what ways and you can actually begin to understand what the program was doing even if it wasn't written in assembly by looking at the assembly yeah definitely i think another area where you see the assembly code is in areas that, as you mentioned earlier, that have high performance requirements. So I know if you look at the Quake 3 source code,
你可以查看实际生成的指令，并开始恢复程序的结构，它在做什么，它是如何以何种方式访问内存的。即使程序不是用汇编编写的，通过查看汇编代码，你也可以开始理解程序在做什么。是的，绝对是这样。我认为你看到汇编代码的另一个领域是正如你之前提到的，那些对性能有极高要求的领域。我知道如果你查看《雷神之锤 3》（Quake 3）的源代码，
I believe there's some blocks of assembly in there where they're dealing with things particular to the physics which had to be executed possibly hundreds or thousands of times a frame. Yep, yep. And those people are really gurus. They have a really specialized task, but when you need them, they're really valuable. Yeah, and maybe we should mention you can actually put assembly inline inside of your C program.
我相信里面有一些汇编代码块，它们处理的是与物理相关的特定内容，这些内容可能每帧需要执行成百上千次。是的，没错。那些人真的是大师。他们有非常专业的任务，但当你需要他们时，他们非常有价值。是的，也许我们应该提到你实际上可以在 C 程序中内联汇编代码。
Have you ever done that? And both C and C++ you can. I have actually done that before, yes. Yeah, I think you use – I've done it once, but it's been a while. But I think you do, what is it? Underscore, underscore ASM. That's right, that's right. And then a curly bracket, and then your assembly instructions.
你做过吗？在 C 和 C++ 中都可以。我确实做过，是的。是的，我想你用的是——我做过一次，但那是很久以前的事了。我想你用的是，是什么来着？双下划线 ASM。没错，没错。然后是一个花括号，接着是你的汇编指令。
Right, so you could have a bunch of C code, and then just in the middle of it, boom, here's some assembly. It's quite scary. Yeah, you can get into trouble, so you have to be very careful about what you're doing. Yeah, I mean, keep in mind that the state isn't pure. So you're writing some assembly code. You might possibly break what's going on. And that's when things like volatile and so on become important. Yeah, you're working in a very specific niche when you're doing those kind of things.
没错，所以你可以有一堆 C 代码，然后在中间，砰，这里有一些汇编代码。这很吓人。是的，你可能会惹上麻烦，所以你必须非常小心你在做什么。是的，我的意思是，记住状态不是纯粹的。所以你正在编写一些汇编代码。你可能会破坏正在运行的东西。这就是 volatile 等关键字变得重要的时候。是的，当你做这些事情时，你是在一个非常特定的利基领域工作。
Right, right. The other thing that I'll mention that's used a lot is interrupt service routines. Because interrupt service routines kind of take the highest priority in a system. So when an interrupt happens, it has to get serviced. And you want to get in and out as fast as possible because you don't want to miss other interrupts. You don't want your program to be paused while that's occurring. So oftentimes,
没错，没错。我要提到的另一件经常使用汇编的事情是中断服务例程（ISR）。因为中断服务例程在系统中具有最高优先级。所以当中断发生时，它必须得到处理。你希望尽快进出，因为你不想错过其他中断。你不想让你的程序在处理过程中被暂停。所以通常情况下，
those will be written in assembly because the object of the ISR is to basically capture what happened, store that somewhere, and then be done and let somebody else do the processing and handling for it. And so in order to make that even faster, those will often be written in assembly. Right, right. And then, of course, in an operating system, many parts are written in an assembly language because you don't have the liberty of using other stuff that relies on the operating system because you're writing it yeah exactly i mean if you're writing like the linux kernel or something like that yeah you can imagine that you know large parts of that are in assembly that's right that's
这些会用汇编编写，因为 ISR 的目标基本上是捕获发生了什么，将其存储在某处，然后完成任务，让其他人进行处理。为了让它更快，这些通常会用汇编编写。没错，没错。当然，在操作系统中，许多部分是用汇编语言编写的，因为你没有自由去使用其他依赖于操作系统的东西，因为你正在编写它。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，如果你正在编写像 Linux 内核之类的东西，是的，你可以想象其中很大一部分是汇编语言。没错，那是
right um not as much as you would think but still still some parts are. Yeah. Right. Yeah. I mean, I guess large in the sense that like large blocks of assembly, but yeah, I mean, I would say, I mean, less than 10% of the whole kernel. That's interesting. Yeah. We should have looked up that. That would have been interesting statistic to find, but yeah. Yeah. I wonder if I see.
没错，嗯，没有你想象的那么多，但仍然有一些部分是。是的。没错。是的，我的意思是，我猜“大”是指像大块的汇编代码，但是的，我的意思是，我会说，不到整个内核的 10%。这很有趣。是的。我们本应该查一下那个。那会是一个有趣的统计数据，但是的。是的，我想知道我是否能看到。
Um, and so of course, over time we kind of move up the higher level language ladder as it were. So you'll find people who have been programming for 20, 25 years. Remember having the only option be writing in assembly. And then as C came out, at first people mistrusted it, right? Oh, there's no way it can be better than me at writing assembly, you know, and they were right and it was not nearly as good. But then over time, it became better and better and it was not nearly as good but then over time it became
嗯，所以随着时间的推移，我们逐渐向高级语言阶梯攀升。所以你会发现那些已经编程 20、25 年的人，记得当时唯一的选择就是用汇编编写。然后当 C 语言出现时，起初人们不信任它，对吧？哦，它不可能比我写汇编更好，你知道，他们是对的，它确实远不如汇编好。但随着时间的推移，它变得越来越好，它远不如汇编好，但随着时间的推移，它变得
better and better and it increased your efficiency at writing so even though your program a c program will never be as fast as a handcrafted assembly thing well i shouldn't say never almost never will be as fast as somebody who hand coded assembly to do the same thing um but it can get close enough that for almost every purpose, it doesn't matter. Right. And even if, you know, it's two times slower, you know, the productivity, one of the things that's really interesting is, you know, computers are increasing an exponential rate, but the productivity of engineers is actually decreasing or staying constant, let's say. And the complexity of the system, the amount of code and effort that's required to build
越来越好，它提高了你的编写效率。所以即使你的程序，一个 C 程序永远不会像手工编写的汇编程序那样快——好吧，我不应该说永远，几乎永远不会像手工编写汇编的人那样快——但它可以足够接近，以至于对于几乎所有目的来说，这都不重要。没错。即使它慢了两倍，你知道，生产力，其中一件非常有趣的事情是，你知道，计算机正以指数级速度增长，但工程师的生产力实际上正在下降或保持不变。而系统的复杂性，构建系统所需的代码量和工作量
systems is increasing at a linear rate. So what's happening, long story short, is that computers are getting much, much faster, but we humans who program them are not. And so if you're going to program in C instead of assembly, even if it's twice as slow, if it makes you as a programmer twice as fast or 10 times as fast, it's worthwhile. Yeah, definitely. And the kind of idea here is if you waste cycles, it's not a big deal because in a few months it'll be, well, that's the way it always used to be. Now that's changing today, but still, it's still kind of in effect at some level that don't worry about wasting cycles
正以线性速度增长。所以长话短说，发生的情况是计算机变得越来越快，但我们这些编程的人类却没有。所以如果你要用 C 语言而不是汇编语言编程，即使它慢了两倍，如果它能让你作为程序员的速度快两倍或十倍，那也是值得的。是的，绝对是。这里的想法是，如果你浪费周期，那没什么大不了的，因为几个月后它就会……好吧，过去一直都是这样。现在情况正在改变，但在某种程度上它仍然有效，即不要担心浪费周期，
because if it's something that only gets executed once it's not a big deal but like we said but if it's something they get executed you know many many many times um then that might be something you want to look at right and systems nowadays are getting so complicated that you know a lot of the time speed ends up coming down to just algorithmic decisions that's that's right that's right sometimes changing the in other words if you hand code bubble sort and assembly you probably still won't necessarily be able to beat a person who codes uh heap sort or quick sort in c or c plus plus right exactly exactly yep so so understanding the algorithm part is important as well that's heap sort or quick sort in C or C++. Right, exactly. So understanding the algorithm part is important as well.
因为如果它只是执行一次的东西，那没什么大不了的。但正如我们所说，如果它是执行很多很多次的东西，那么那可能就是你想关注的事情。没错，现在的系统变得如此复杂，以至于很多时候速度最终归结为算法决策。没错，没错。有时改变……换句话说，如果你用汇编手工编写冒泡排序，你可能仍然不一定能打败一个在 C 或 C++ 中编写堆排序或快速排序的人。没错，完全正确。是的，所以理解算法部分也很重要。堆排序或快速排序在 C 或 C++ 中。没错，完全正确。所以理解算法部分也很重要。
That's definitely true. That's often overlooked. People just pick an algorithm and then they just kind of assume that's what they're going to go with and then they just try to make the algorithm as fast as possible instead of considering changing algorithms. Yeah, definitely.
这绝对是真的。这经常被忽视。人们只是选择一个算法，然后就假设他们要用那个算法，然后他们只是试图让算法尽可能快，而不是考虑更换算法。是的，绝对是。
So we've sort of hinted at this, but the strengths of assembly language are that you have complete control of the hardware. You're not coding to any virtual machine as in Python or Java. And you're not relying on some expensive and lossy and somewhat bloated, with respect to hand-coded, a bloated compiler like C or C++, you directly know what's going on with the memory and the processor, and you can very accurately estimate the timing of a certain block of assembly. And it really sort of makes you one with the hardware. Your zen with the hardware is much increased.
所以我们已经暗示了这一点，但汇编语言的优势在于你拥有对硬件的完全控制权。你不是在为任何虚拟机编码，就像 Python 或 Java 那样。你也不依赖于昂贵、有损且相对于手工编码而言臃肿的编译器，比如 C 或 C++。你直接知道内存和处理器在发生什么，并且你可以非常准确地估计某个汇编代码块的计时。它真的让你与硬件合二为一。你与硬件的禅意大大增加了。
Yeah, even if you don't go write all your code in assembly, if you know assembly for a given processor, it's going to help you write better C code for that processor. Right, that's right. I mean, if you know that the processor only has, you know, one register or two or a handful of registers, then that might change the way that you handle memory on your system.
是的，即使你不去用汇编编写所有的代码，如果你了解特定处理器的汇编，它也会帮助你为该处理器编写更好的 C 代码。没错，没错。我的意思是，如果你知道处理器只有一个、两个或少数几个寄存器，那么这可能会改变你处理系统内存的方式。
And you might try and do things in a more data-independent way. But it does lead to a bunch of weaknesses. Well, not a bunch. One is just absolute tediousness. If you had to write a large-scale program, what might be a 10,000-line-of-code C program in assembly, it would be ridiculous and very, very hard to maintain. And I'm not saying that nobody has ever done it, but the maintainability is a lot worse.
你可能会尝试以更独立于数据的方式做事。但这确实导致了一堆弱点。好吧，不是一堆。一个是绝对的繁琐。如果你必须编写一个大型程序，比如一个 1 万行的 C 程序，用汇编编写将是荒谬的，而且非常非常难以维护。我并不是说没有人这样做过，但可维护性要差得多。
Right, I mean, just think of this simple expression, X equals Y. Well, in assembly, you have to find where Y is in memory. You have to load that into one of your registers. You'd have to load x into, or actually, let's say it was, sorry, let's say it was x equals y plus z. You would have to load y, you'd have to load z.
没错，我的意思是，想想这个简单的表达式，X 等于 Y。好吧，在汇编中，你必须找到 Y 在内存中的位置。你必须将其加载到你的寄存器中。你必须加载 X 到……或者实际上，让我们说，抱歉，让我们说它是 X 等于 Y 加 Z。你必须加载 Y，你必须加载 Z。
Then you'd have to perform the add operation and put that result in a new register. And then you'd have to put that register into x. So I mean, all these different instructions for something that's just five or six characters and c that's right that's right there can be a very and that's for a simple case that's if uh they were all native integers to that machine right that's right if x and y are classes or or shorts or something else yeah you got oh yeah if they're like characters you have to do all sorts of masking as well.
然后你必须执行加法操作并将结果放入一个新的寄存器中。然后你必须将该寄存器放入 X。所以我的意思是，所有这些不同的指令，对于在 C 语言中只有五六个字符的东西来说。没错，没错，这可能是一个非常……而且这还是针对简单情况，如果它们都是该机器的原生整数的话。没错，没错，如果 X 和 Y 是类、短整型或其他东西。是的，你得……哦，是的，如果它们是字符，你还得做各种掩码操作。
So, yeah, so tediousness. The other thing is it's basically the antithesis of portability. Yeah, that's right. The code is not portable. You're coding for that one CPU. Yeah, and now I should mention that if you, for instance, code for a Core 2 Duo processor, which is an Intel x86 architecture, what that x86 architecture that you hear people talking about and the ability to run executable on one Windows PC and on another Windows PC or one MacBook and another MacBook that may have different specific processors, but they're in the same family that has to do with the fact that they have the same opcode that x86 family is the same set of opcode instructions so they're binary compatible with each other right yeah oh and that actually brings in a lot more but we'll skip it for now um now i did want to say as far as if you're interested i wouldn't recommend assembly as the
所以，是的，繁琐。另一件事是它基本上是可移植性的对立面。是的，没错。代码不可移植。你是为那一个 CPU 编码的。是的，现在我应该提到，如果你例如为 Core 2 Duo 处理器编码，它是 Intel x86 架构，你听到人们谈论的那个 x86 架构，以及在 Windows PC 上和另一台 Windows PC 上，或者一台 MacBook 和另一台 MacBook 上运行可执行文件的能力，它们可能有不同的特定处理器，但它们属于同一个家族，这与它们拥有相同的操作码有关，x86 家族是同一套操作码指令，所以它们在二进制上是兼容的。没错，是的，哦，这实际上带来了更多内容，但我们现在先跳过它。嗯，现在我确实想说，如果你感兴趣的话，我不建议汇编作为你学习的
first language you learn um but I definitely do recommend it as something to at least spend a little bit of time with and learning because it will teach you a lot about how a computer really works at the lowest level but you don't have to learn on a complicated machine like an x86 instruction set or an ARM instruction set they actually have toy languages and toy I don't mean there in a demeaning way but very simplistic CPU architectures and assemblers that will work for those so that you can practice on a you know for register 8-bit CPU that you know has only like
第一门语言，但我绝对建议把它作为至少花一点时间去学习的东西，因为它会教你很多关于计算机在最低层面上是如何真正工作的知识。但你不必在复杂的机器上学习，比如 x86 指令集或 ARM 指令集。它们实际上有玩具语言，我说的玩具不是贬义，而是非常简单的 CPU 架构和汇编器，它们可以工作，这样你就可以在一个你知道的 4 寄存器 8 位 CPU 上练习，它只有像
two or three instructions and practice moving stuff around and actually they'll have the simulator will show you where the instructions are moving how the processor is executing and that and that's a very informative and enlightening thing and um i don't have any right now to recommend they're all out there if you just search around for them you'll find them and yeah that's something i recommend i'll make a shameless plug for a open source project i work on called maim which is multiple Arcade Machine Emulator. And what MAME does is it, as the name suggests, it emulates the processors that were used for just about any of the arcade machines that were from all the way from Pong all the way up to around the mid-90s. And so you can go into any of these processor drivers,
两三条指令，练习移动东西，实际上模拟器会向你展示指令在哪里移动，处理器是如何执行的，这是一种非常有启发性和启蒙性的事情。嗯，我现在没有任何推荐的，如果你四处搜索，你会找到它们的。是的，这是我推荐的。我要为我参与的一个名为 MAME（多重街机模拟器）的开源项目做一个无耻的广告。MAME 所做的是，顾名思义，它模拟了从 Pong 一直到 90 年代中期几乎所有街机所使用的处理器。所以你可以进入任何这些处理器驱动程序，
and what you'll see is a software assembler. So you'll see something which can read in the assembly language for that processor and convert each of the op codes into or represent each of the things in C. So for example the command that loads a variable from memory to a register, if you look at in the main source code for any one of those processors, what you'll see the load instruction do is it will essentially copy the variable from one location to another because it's all done in C. someone has written a C emulator for the machine, and you can sort of get a feel for what assembly looks like and what an assembler does by looking at that source code without having to actually mess with x86.
你会看到的是一个软件汇编器。所以你会看到一些可以读取该处理器汇编语言并将每个操作码转换或用 C 语言表示的东西。例如，将变量从内存加载到寄存器的命令，如果你查看任何这些处理器的 MAME 源代码，你会看到加载指令所做的是，它本质上是将变量从一个位置复制到另一个位置，因为这一切都是用 C 语言完成的。有人为该机器编写了一个 C 模拟器，你可以通过查看该源代码来感受汇编的样子以及汇编器的工作原理，而无需真正去折腾 x86。
Yeah, because if you start writing in assembly, you can definitely cause very easily problems to happen on your computer. Oh, yeah, definitely. And there's also a lot of. Oh yeah, definitely. So, and there's also a lot of good books because the way, like I said, this is the only thing people used to have. Now we have many choices of programming languages. You know, 20 years ago you didn't have as many and so there's a lot of learning material out there, a lot of good books that are written and then, you know, a lot
是的，因为如果你开始用汇编编写代码，你绝对很容易导致计算机出现问题。哦，是的，绝对是。而且还有很多。哦，是的，绝对是。所以，还有很多好书，因为正如我所说，这是人们过去唯一拥有的东西。现在我们有很多编程语言的选择。你知道，20 年前你没有那么多选择，所以有很多学习资料，有很多写得很好的书，然后，你知道，很多人，
of people, and I think I'm one of these people, I think that if you really want to be really good at writing programs, at some point, you're going to have to learn assembler. Even if you never write a real program in assembly for your work, for your job, understanding is going to be invaluable to helping you write good code. Yeah, for sure. Not that I'm fussing at you, Jason, for not having done that before, but. Well, you know, to be fair fair I did it in college I've just
而且我认为我也是这些人之一，我认为如果你真的想非常擅长编写程序，在某个时候，你必须学习汇编语言。即使你工作中从不编写真正的汇编程序，理解它对于帮助你编写好的代码也是无价的。是的，当然。并不是我在责怪你，Jason，因为你之前没有这样做过，但是。好吧，你知道，公平地说，我在大学里做过，我只是
completely forgotten about it oh okay you need to increase it from counting on one hand to counting on all fingers and toes at least yeah I guess that's true I guess that's true so but um yeah I definitely encourage you guys all assembly it's kind of a it's not a specific language but it is this you know kind of a group of languages and it definitely has a lot to offer and it's something good in everybody's toolbox yeah for sure definitely knowing about assembly will give you insight to how your computer works that's never a bad thing that's right well do you have anything else sir i think that's it so i hope oh go ahead oh i was just gonna say thank you for those of you writing reviews i saw we had a couple more so i definitely thank you for that we're very grateful for you guys are saying really nice things it helps us keep going knowing that you guys are out there
完全忘记了。哦，好吧，你需要把它从用一只手计数增加到至少用所有的手指和脚趾计数。是的，我想那是真的，我想那是真的。所以，但是嗯，是的，我绝对鼓励你们所有人学习汇编，它不是一种特定的语言，但它是一种，你知道，某种语言组，它绝对有很多东西可以提供，而且它是每个人工具箱里很好的东西。是的，当然，了解汇编绝对会让你深入了解计算机的工作原理，这永远不是坏事。没错，好吧，你还有什么要说的吗，先生？我想就是这样了。所以我希望……哦，请继续。哦，我只是想说谢谢那些写评论的人，我看到我们又多了几个，所以我绝对感谢你们。我们非常感谢你们，你们说的话非常好，知道你们在外面，这有助于我们继续前进。
enjoying this and tell your friends about it email some people get your parents to listen you know whoever we don't really care one and all welcome to the programming throwdown and learn something yeah definitely we did get an email we got a fan mail let's see if i there's one that was like particularly interesting and i'm pulling up the uh programming throwdown right now all right yeah and so um if you again you want to check out our website it's programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com. So feel free to go there. We post show notes, links to the news we talked about, and kind of a summary of what we discussed about the programming language.
享受这个节目，告诉你的朋友，给一些人发邮件，让你父母听，你知道，无论谁，我们真的不在乎，欢迎来到 Programming Throwdown 并学习一些东西。是的，绝对是。我们确实收到了一封邮件，我们收到了粉丝来信，让我们看看我是否……有一封特别有趣的，我正在打开 Programming Throwdown。好的，是的，所以嗯，如果你再次想查看我们的网站，它是 programmingthrowdown.blogspot.com。所以请随时去那里。我们发布节目笔记、我们谈论的新闻链接，以及我们讨论的编程语言的总结。
And also a link to the download, which obviously you've already found because you're listening to this. Or, of course, you can subscribe to us on iTunes and get it that way. Whatever works for you. Yeah, we got a mail from Justin. We probably shouldn't give away his last name. Yeah, that's fine. Because I hate when people do that to me. But yeah, Justin wrote to us.
还有一个下载链接，显然你已经找到了，因为你正在听这个。或者，当然，你可以在 iTunes 上订阅我们并以这种方式获取。任何适合你的方式都可以。是的，我们收到了 Justin 的来信。我们可能不应该透露他的姓氏。是的，没关系。因为我讨厌别人对我那样做。但是的，Justin 给我们写信了。
He said he wanted to hear some more about network security, which is, you know, I've never really gotten into network security. But, you know, I have a lot of friends who are really into like cryptography and all that stuff and it's one of those things that you know i don't understand personally but i know a lot of people who are alert by network security and uh so we will definitely try to um you know talk about that and there's definitely more that we can say about that yeah i know he asked to talk about malware analysis and talking about assembly this week um definitely is something that if you're going to do malware analysis reverse engineering
他说他想多听听关于网络安全的内容，你知道，我从来没有真正深入研究过网络安全。但是，你知道，我有很多朋友非常热衷于密码学之类的东西，这是那种你知道我个人不理解，但我认识很多对网络安全很警觉的人的事情，所以我们一定会尝试，你知道，谈论那个，而且关于那个我们肯定还有更多可以说的。是的，我知道他要求谈论恶意软件分析，而本周谈论汇编，如果你要进行恶意软件分析、逆向工程，
you you have to know assembly yeah i mean all these guys who write especially these these trojans that automatically infect other executables and things like that yes um they're definitely doing that at the assembly level yeah those guys who write self-modifying code, because like I said, instructions are just some other place in memory, so you can write code that modifies itself. And some modern operating systems prevent you from doing that for good reason, because most of the time if you're doing that, you're a virus. Right.
你必须了解汇编。是的，我的意思是，所有这些编写木马的人，特别是那些自动感染其他可执行文件之类的木马的人，是的，嗯，他们绝对是在汇编层面做这些事情。是的，那些编写自修改代码的人，因为正如我所说，指令只是内存中的其他位置，所以你可以编写修改自身的代码。一些现代操作系统出于正当理由阻止你这样做，因为大多数时候如果你这样做，你就是病毒。没错。
But yeah, it's like you can write code that modifies itself on the fly. Yeah. Well, thanks, Justin, for writing. And, yeah, if anyone else has any more comments or anything else that they want to tell us, send us an email at programmingthrowdown at gmail.com. All right. Well, I think that's a wrap. Until next time.
但是的，就像你可以编写即时修改自身的代码一样。是的。好吧，谢谢 Justin 的来信。而且，是的，如果还有其他人有更多评论或任何他们想告诉我们的事情，请发送电子邮件至 programmingthrowdown@gmail.com。好的，好吧，我想这就是结束了。下次见。
Have a good one, guys. Take care. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. guys. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
祝你们过得愉快，伙计们。保重。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。伙计们。保重。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。